So, und dann kann ich nochmal hier ein bisschen mit den Funktionen rumspielen.
Was geht denn da noch? Mal schauen, ob du das jetzt hier hören würdest.
Oh ja, da gibt es einen Lautstärke.
Es faded ein. Das ist das Coole.
Was ich auch ganz witzig finde, es gibt auch, das nennt sich Soundboard Ducking.
Wenn ich das anmache, dann kann ich das abspielen. Pass mal auf.
Und wenn ich jetzt drüber rede.
Uh, wie cool.
Ja, auch wenn du darüber redest, dann kann man
vielleicht drüber reden.
Also haben wir die ganze Zeit jetzt das Intro im Hintergrund
laufen, kontinuierlich. Vielleicht, ja.
Vor allem wäre das voll praktisch für die
Leute, die so dumme Features wie Smart Speed
nutzen, was automatisch Silences überspringt,
weil dann können wir das unterbinden.
Das mache ich, das habe ich
zum Beispiel an. Ich auch.
Ich liebe dieses Feature.
Das ist großartig. Warum sollte das jemals
jemand abschalten wollen?
Laut Overcast hat mir das schon 250
Stunden. Echt jetzt, ja.
Na Kean, was hast du so in der letzten Zeit gemacht?
Super viel.
Hab so viel geschafft wie noch nie in meinem Leben.
Echt jetzt? Bist du noch zu Hause oder gehst du auch schon wieder arbeiten?
Nee, nee.
Das war jetzt auch sehr erotisch gemeint durch das ständige Daheim-Rumsitzen.
Ich hab tatsächlich letztens im Baumarkt gewesen
und dieses Brett, was du da hinter mir sehen kannst im Fenster,
hab ich gebaut, damit die Katzen da oben chillen können,
was tatsächlich jetzt gerade in Anspruch genommen wird.
Das war das erste Mal, dass ich jetzt was, also diesem Klischee entspreche, dass ich muss hier was mal, was Praktisches anfassen.
Und da hast du was mit Holz gemacht quasi.
Dann habe ich wirklich was mit Holz gemacht.
Geil, ich habe mich auch ein bisschen handwerklich betätigt.
Ich habe eine Woche Urlaub gemacht und zwar habe ich einfach einen Heimaturlaub gemacht und meine Familie besucht.
mich extra vorher zwei Wochen lang irgendwie komplett eingesperrt
und mich nur aus dem Kühlschrank ernährt und mein Kühlschrank leigegeessen
und keine Menschen getroffen, damit ich mich trauen kann, meine Familie zu besuchen.
Und dann habe ich mir da von meiner Mutter beibringen lassen,
wie ich mit einer Nähmaschine umgehe.
Und jetzt habe ich meine eigene kleine Kollektion
von selbstgeschneiderten Masken,
die ich aus alten Hemden von mir gesäbelt habe.
Sieht schick aus.
Also das hier war kein Hemd von mir.
Ich habe kein Prilblumenhemd.
Das war einfach so ein Stoff, aber ich fand das lustig.
und das hat irgendwie Spaß gemacht.
Das war so meine Beschäftigung.
Für einen Tag oder zwei.
Genau.
Achso, jetzt wurde es abgesagt wegen der letzten Woche.
Ich war Anfang der Woche noch auf der UI-Conf,
so eine Konferenz, die eigentlich jährlich in Berlin stattfindet.
Diesmal leider natürlich nicht, sondern bei jedem daheim.
Aber war echt ganz cool.
Das ist eigentlich so, also ich weiß gar nicht,
warum die eigentlich UI-Conf heißt, vielleicht historische Gründe.
Ist das eine für App-Entwickler oder?
Ja, hauptsächlich sogar mit Apple-Focus auch noch.
Also es ist nicht so großartig auf UI-Themen ausgelegt oder so,
wie gesagt, so heißt.
Aber war eigentlich ganz, ganz cool
und hat ein paar spannende Talks gehabt.
Auch einen, den ich sehr empfehlen kann,
die hoffentlich bald dann mit online sind,
zum Allgemeinverzehr, zum Thema Geschichte von Unicode
und warum Emoji so geil sind und generell Unicode.
Was man alles, was damit Spaß machen kann.
hat ein bisschen hier mit Swift-String-API
sich durch Unicode geforstet
und so klassische Sachen gemacht wie
Zalgo oder
durch ein paar Joiner-Emoji
im Handy zusammengebaut und was da alles so geht.
Ah, nice, okay.
Weißt du, was wir total vergessen haben?
Was denn?
Hi, Kilian!
Hey, Hendrik!
Das ist der offizielle Start der Folge.
Ja, offenbar.
Wir haben jetzt mit der
Pre-Show schon so seicht
eingefangen, dass wir überhaupt nicht so diesen richtigen Einstieg
vielleicht, wollen wir es einfach nochmal ein bisschen machen?
Nochmal machen?
Ach Quatsch, das machen wir jetzt direkt.
Das bleibt jetzt gerade die Sendung.
Das bleibt jetzt so. Na pass auf, dann machen wir es wenigstens so, dass wir jetzt sagen
ähm
Hi Kilian!
Hey Hendrik!
Ja, die Musik muss sein. Stark.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Hätte ich schon erwartet, dass die irgendwann kommt.
Ich muss bloß irgendwann diesen Knopf drücken,
sonst passt es irgendwie nicht.
Wir machen das ja jetzt live, das ist ja nicht mehr
im Editor nach. Ich habe überlegt,
normalerweise mache ich einfach,
jetzt kommt hier ein Blick hinter die Akronomisierbar-Kulissen,
normalerweise lasse ich ja vorher einfach
während unserer Pre-Show einfach schon mal
die ganze Zeit das Band laufen, um irgendwie
irgendeinen dummen Spruch zu capturen, um diesen
Gag zu schneiden und dann
schneide ich das Ding da rein.
Die letzten zwei Mal habe ich es
hier mit dem Soundport gemacht.
Und dann ist es lustig,
wir hören, dann selber live während der Aufnahme der Musik
zu hören. Das machen wir normalerweise ja gar nicht.
Deswegen ist dir das jetzt gar nicht so sehr aufgefallen.
Da hab ich jetzt gedacht, wo tu ich jetzt die Musik hin?
Bis vor vier Folgen hab ich komplett
vergessen, wie unser Jingle eigentlich klingt, weil ich das
nie gehört hab. Nicht Spaß.
Aber ich hab
gehört, du machst jetzt deinen
eigenen Podcast.
Ach so, ja. Stimmt. Ich glaub, wir haben
gar nicht mehr Akonnentüre aufgenommen, seitdem
Hallo Swift jetzt neu gelauncht wurde.
Du bist jetzt der neue Host von Hallo Swift?
Zusammen mit
Bidal und ich haben den übernommen quasi,
weil das Projekt schon lange nicht mehr weitergeführt wurde,
leider, aus diversen Gründen.
Und haben den jetzt gerebootet,
sprich, wenn ihr ein bisschen von uns geschwafelt hören wollt,
über Dinge aus dem Swift-Ecosystem,
jetzt nicht nur spezifisch auf die Sprache bezogen,
in der aktuellsten Folge, die gerade draußen ist,
ging es um Contact-Tracing und Bluetooth
und davor um Combine, Apples Reactive-Framework
und genau, nehme ich es auch weiter wieder über Swift an sich,
Sprache gehen. Wenn ihr dem lauschen
wollt, geht einfach mal auf hallo-swift.de.
Ihr habt da ja wirklich relativ viele
Folgen auf einmal rausgehauen.
Ja, das war so fast im Wochentakt.
Wir haben von Anfang an eigentlich vorgenommen,
nicht im Wochentakt Folgen aufzunehmen, aber
am Anfang hat es gerade so gepasst. Wir wollen eher
sowas zwei-, dreiwöchiges anpeilen,
wenn möglich, damit man auch
nicht ganz so schnell so ein Burnout
davon hat. Nicht so wie bei
Akronomisierbar,
obwohl ihr vor lauter Release-Geschwindigkeit
echt richtig die Ohren schlackern.
Move fast and break things, genau
Apropos break things
weißt du, was ich schon wieder vergessen habe?
Ich habe das Ethernet nicht angeschlossen
ich bin jetzt wieder über WLAN drin
aber Latenz scheint jetzt gar nicht mal so schlimm
zu sein, es geht, ne?
Ja, aktuell geht es nicht ganz gut
Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass es
Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass bei mir gerade im Haus keiner
Netflix guckt um die Uhrzeit
Das ist noch so tagsüber, nicht abends
Tagsüber am Samstag
Was haben wir denn heute für Themen?
Wir haben ziemlich viel im Pad langsam
zusammengesammelt. Erstmal so grob
die News anschneiden, von wegen, dass
irgendwelche Firmen gegessen wurden von anderen Firmen,
was wir irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ein Ding
draus machen, wenn uns das interessiert, das immer
anzusprechen. Wer ist denn diesmal
von Microsoft gekauft worden?
Ich verlege gerade nicht,
dass Microsoft wirklich noch eine Acquisition hatte,
aber nee, ich glaube nicht, was ich mitbekommen hätte.
Nee, Keybase wurde
gekauft. Nicht, dass ich, dass wir glaube ich,
also wir waren beide auf Keybase, wir haben auch
und wir mal den Chat benutzt vor Jahren.
Aber immer bloß so mit einem Jahr
Abstand dazwischen oder so.
Gigantische Latenz.
Aber die Plattform an sich fand ich eigentlich immer
ganz cool, dass die halt da was angehen von wegen
hier normalen Leuten
PGP slash GPG näher bringen.
Auch wenn das immer ein bisschen
weirder war, weil du auch deinen privaten Key hochladen konntest,
was aber man nicht machen musste.
Aber das konnte man von Anfang an.
Und irgendwie haben die es dann immer weiter ausgebaut.
Die hatten dann irgendwann noch diese Stellar Lumens
als ihre eigene Kryptowährung.
Du hast diesem Ding relativ schnell angemerkt, das war zumindest so mein Eindruck von Keybase, das war ein Startup, die hatten eine Idee, die gut war und zwar, wir machen GPG einfach und machen das benutzbar und erlauben dir deine ganzen einzelnen Sachen zu sein.
Das war eigentlich das einzige Feature, was ich wirklich benutzen wollte, dass du irgendwie sagen kannst, meine Identity, mein Twitter und mein GitHub.
Genau, also du kannst die ganzen alle zusammenbinden dort.
Genau, kann ich irgendwie angeben, dass das alles wirklich ich bin, indem ich das irgendwie alles seine.
Aber danach kam nur noch so aus meiner persönlichen Ansicht so Quatsch-Features dazu, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das brauche ich jetzt echt nicht.
Ja, so ein paar Sachen hatten die schon noch ganz cool.
Also den Chat bei den Wegen, keine Ahnung, das war jetzt nicht so, finde ich, mega sinnvoll bei denen.
Dann hatten sie auch so Shared File System,
das fand ich gar nicht so gut. Genau, das fand ich eigentlich ganz
geil, vor allem auch die
Encrypted Git-Geschichte,
dass du halt ein Git-Remote
komplett verschlüsselt auf,
ich weiß gar nicht, müsste ja über deren
Server gelaufen sein, aber eben komplett verschlüsselt, lokal
bei dir, da hatte ich mir meine Steuererklärung
mal reingeworfen, testweise,
habe ich jetzt gesehen, als ich das vor drei Tagen,
vor zwei Wochen gelöscht habe oder wann das war.
War nicht schlecht.
Aber es ist halt komisch gewesen,
weil die waren halt so ein Startup mit haufenweise Ideen
und die haben halt nie wirklich Geld gemacht,
laut Hacker News Kommentaren. Und irgendwann kam sie halt noch
auf die Idee, allen Nutzern Geld zu schenken
durch ihr ICO.
Beziehungsweise, na ICO war das eigentlich
gar nicht. Die haben eher Kryptowährung einfach ins Leben
gerufen und haben jedem Nutzer da
hier x von geschenkt. Ich hab die vor ein paar
Tagen noch in Bitcoin getauscht. Das waren ungefähr 100 Dollar
zu dem aktuellen Zeitpunkt.
Aber, hm.
Naja, wenn du irgendwie Geld mit
einer Kryptowährung machen willst, musst du dafür sorgen, dass
das Leute benutzen und wie machst du das, dass das Leute benutzen?
Indem du es Leuten einfach schenkst.
Ja, weiß nicht.
Irgendwie, naja, die wurden jetzt halt wegen
auf jeden Fall von Zoom gekauft, was interessant war.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das zustande kam.
Wir brauchen unbedingt irgendwas mit Verschlüsselung,
damit wir auch was mit
Verschlüsselung machen können.
Wer kennt sich denn hier mit Verschlüsselung aus?
Such mal noch irgendwas mit Schlüsseln.
Key, das muss irgendeine
Gruppe sein. Genau, raten einfach.
Keybase, gibt es sowas wie Keybase?
Was machen die? Kaufen wir einfach mal.
ich habe keine Ahnung, was die mit denen anfangen wollen,
weil die beiden Produkte
overlappen halt an keiner Stelle so gefühlt.
Aber vielleicht haben die
ja wirklich bloß hier einen Echo-Hire draus gemacht
und sich Experten ins Boot geholt,
die das schon länger Erfahrung mit haben. Aber so groß war das
Keybase-Team glaube ich auch nicht. Aber gut,
ich habe keine Ahnung. Die haben zumindest
Erfahrung mit sehr vielen unterschiedlichen
Use-Cases für Krypto, weil sie
mit ihrem Chat und ihrem Git und ihrem FS
und ihrem Cross-Signing
relativ viele Sachen gemacht haben,
die unterschiedlich sind.
Wahrscheinlich könnte man die deshalb wirklich ganz gut zurechnen,
dass sie sich irgendwie jetzt einem neuen Problem,
nämlich zum Beispiel Realtime Communication widmen.
Mal schauen.
War ein bisschen komisch, weil Zoom zu dem Zeitpunkt
beziehungsweise immer noch diesen faden Beigeschmack hat
von Firmen, die viel zu schnell gewachsen ist in der aktuellen Krise
und alles verkackt, was zu verkacken ist.
Aber na ja, vielleicht kriegen die ja doch,
vielleicht ist es ja auch gar nicht malicious alles bei denen.
Vielleicht ist es ja einfach nur Unfähigkeit und Überraschung
über die eigene Popularität.
und jetzt kriegen die alles in den Griff
und alles ist super, wer weiß.
Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall gibt es noch
eine Alternative, die ich gefunden hatte.
Keys.pub.
Das ist dann hinterher so ein bisschen rumgegangen.
Kannst du mir mal erzählen, was das ist?
Ja, es ist nicht so ganz eine Alternative
für das, was alles Keybase macht. Die haben aber
die Möglichkeit, dass du
ein grafisches Tool hast, mit dem du Dinge
verschlüsseln kannst, verifizieren kannst,
ob die Signaturen passen und so weiter
und darüber storen kannst. Ich weiß nicht genau,
also prinzipiell ist einfach nur eine Grün für Key Management,
macht aber noch,
also die wollen auch dieses,
was von dir so betitelte Cross-Signing irgendwie mit reinmachen,
so im Sinne von,
du kannst Nutzer-Ad-Service irgendwie ansprechen.
Wie genau da die Verifications laufen,
ob das auf dieselbe Art und Weise wie mit Keybase machen,
im Sinne von, ich poste hier ein Gist,
wo das drinsteht, um zu verifieren,
oder ein Tweet oder wie auch immer.
Wahrscheinlich, aber keine Ahnung.
So genau habe ich es mir nicht angeschaut.
Aber ist zumindest ein Ansatz für eine Alternative.
Ist das auch GPG-basiert dann?
Oder wie funktioniert das?
Oder was macht man überhaupt wirklich genau damit?
Weil hier stehen wieder 35 Sachen drin.
Es gibt irgendwie Saltpack und Wormhole.
Also unten drunter steht jetzt,
dass sie per Default einen ED25519-Key nutzen
zum Sign- und Encrypten von Daten.
Also prinzipiell ist die,
was für einen Key du da benutzt,
ja herrlich egal.
Ich meine, ED25519 kennen wir ja auch die meisten,
die das als SSH-Key nutzen.
Schön kurze RSA-Alternative.
Aber ist das
GPG-kompatibel?
Gibt es da irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung.
Gut, so genau habe ich mir nicht
angeschaut, was ich so gehe.
Klassischer Akronomisierbar.
Gefährliches Halbwissen.
Hier sind Infos. Schaut es euch selber an,
wenn ihr es anschauen wollt.
Akronomisierbar.
41 Folgen zusammengefasst.
Oh, guck mal, das sieht lustig aus.
schaut ihr euch das mal.
Scheiße.
Wir nehmen Podcast ja auch auf.
Demnächst machen wir
Newsletter und droppen einfach nur noch rein in den Links.
Das hatte ich mal überlegt,
was ich als Format ziemlich schön finde,
um mal das Thema jetzt komplett hier zu
kapern, ist diese
Serie, ist dieses
Konzept des This Week In.
Da gibt es ja, ich weiß
nicht, wer das ursprünglich losgetreten war.
Ich persönlich, das Erste, was ich kannte,
This Week in Rust, da gab es aber wahrscheinlich noch
Vorgänger und es gibt
This Week in Matrix, was gut funktioniert, es gibt auch
This Week in Firefox und This Week in
hast nicht gesehen, da gibt es relativ
viele und dieses Format
von ich aggregiere einfach viel und schmeiße
es auf eine Liste zusammen, ohne
dass ich da jetzt unbedingt
Das ist ja
ein bisschen was anderes, oder? Weil das ist ja
eine Sammlung an Topics, die explizit aus diesem
Ecosystem gerade so als News sind. Genau.
Und nicht so random shit.
Genau, aber
die
This Week in Rust gibt es jetzt als Podcast.
Nice.
Und
das fand ich eigentlich so als Konzept ziemlich cool.
Die Matrix-Leute machen die nicht sogar auch einen Podcast über
IAS? Das ist, also was
du in dem TWIM, im This Week in Matrix,
mit drin hast, sind diese Matrix-Live-Videos,
wo zu irgendeinem
Thema, orthogonal zu
dem eigentlichen Newsletter noch irgendwas erzählt wird,
zu was Spezifischem. In letzter Zeit
war es zum Beispiel Carthas Cross-Signing, was neu rauskam.
In der aktuellsten Ausgabe von gestern
Matthew und Amandine zusammen mit dem
WordPress-Typen,
dessen Namen ich vergessen habe, dass
Automatic ja jetzt haufenweise Millionen
in New Vector gesteckt hat, was ich
ganz cool finde und
reden halt da über ein Thema, was halt
relevant ist und nicht so sehr über
This Week in Matrix als Zusammenfassung.
Es gab auch schon die This Week in Matrix-Folge,
wo ich in Matrix Live mit drin war
und über Neo reden durfte. Ach cool, das muss ich nochmal
nachgucken, dann kannst du mal in die Show noch ausschmeißen.
Finde ich nicht mehr spontan, aber es gibt
wahrscheinlich dann nächste Woche mal noch eine,
weil hier jetzt geheime Info
nur für akronomisierbar Hörer,
die Mobile Client
Devs mal eine kurze Runde machen werden,
um einen Überblick über das
Mobile Client Ecosystem von Matrix zu geben.
Nice.
Ist das eine Waschmaschine eigentlich im Hintergrund?
Scheiße, hört man das?
Ich hatte die Hoffnung, dass man das nicht hört.
Sekunde, kannst du ja mal kurz rausschneiden.
Ja, wir können eine kurze Pause machen.
Okay.
Tür mal zugemacht.
Ich hatte das auch schon, deswegen habe ich meine Maschine
heute schon früh angesetzt
gehabt. Ich dachte irgendwie,
das Pluiete hier ist besser, Umgebungsgeräusche
nicht so weit. Nee, das nimmt eher sogar relativ
viel vom Raum auf.
Ja, aber warum denn mit der Nierencharakteristik?
Das ist doch gerade das Feature, warum ich die nutze, dass es das nicht
tut. Naja, es nimmt halt schon
eher in die Richtung auf,
aber du hast halt
auch nicht so wirklich den optimalen Raum, du hast
jetzt nicht unbedingt
Scheißschlucken des Zeugs bei dir rumstehen, außer vielleicht
dieses komische Katzending da im Hintergrund.
Ich habe jetzt, es gibt
ein neues YouTube-Video,
es gibt ein neues Musikvideo von OKGO.
OKGO macht ja immer
absolut supergeile
Musikvideos und die haben eins gemacht, was
einfach, wie alle jetzt gerade,
komplett remote aufgenommen haben, wo jeder bei sich
zu Hause hockt. Und da hat auch
einer die Audio-Parts bei
sich im
Schrank aufgenommen. Da siehst du, wie er
in so einem begehbaren Kleiderschrank steht und da
Jacken um ihn drum herum hängen. Einfach weil das
von der Akustik her schluckt.
Bei mir
helfen jetzt die Teppiche, die ich hier
liegen habe, so ein bisschen.
Aber normalerweise ist es egal, wenn das Mikrofon
einfach in die eine Richtung aufnimmt
und dein
Schall aber durch den ganzen Raum
halt, dann hilft das nicht sonderlich.
Wir brauchen einfach bessere
Audio-Technik, die gefühlt direkt
in meinem Hirn sitzt, wo ich halt
gar nicht physisch sprechen muss, sondern
meine Gedanken halt direkt.
Das hat ja auch nicht mit Audio zu tun.
Dann könnten wir den Podcast auch im Schlaf produzieren.
Einfach so die Träume vor Podcast.
Man macht wirklich sowas und Leute
broadcasten so random Gedanken und Gefühle
von allen möglichen
Situationen.
Das gibt es quasi schon. Es nennt sich Twitter.
Nice, okay.
So, gut, okay.
Wollen wir nochmal ein anderes Thema anschneiden?
Wir waren gerade noch bei
Wir haben noch die andere
Acquisition, die
in letzter Zeit waren. Achso, ich wollte eigentlich noch
zu Ende erzählen.
Was ich spannend finde, ist
bei This Week in Rust, wie gesagt,
das gibt es jetzt als Podcast. Das kriege ich schon
irgendwie wieder zusammengeschnitten.
Es gibt einen Podcast, der heißt
Rustation Station.
Das ist ein Community-Driven
Podcast, also nicht so richtig, aber
die sagen auch, wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr gerne unsere
Folgen für uns schneiden.
Geht natürlich niemand drauf ein.
Ich habe überlegt, ob man vielleicht einfach mal selber was postet
oder denen was schickt.
Aber man muss sich da auch die Zeit nehmen
und irgendwie ein Interviewen oder sowas.
Aber jetzt hat sich zumindest die Person,
oder eine der Personen, die This Week in Rust redigiert,
heißt es redigiert, gedacht, gut, okay,
da machen wir jetzt eigentlich einfach wöchentlich
mal so einen 5-Minuten-Podcast zu This Week in Rust
und dann liest sie einfach quasi This Week in Rust ins Mikrofon
und dann wird das, es gab jetzt erst
eine Folge, mal schauen, wie gut das funktioniert.
Finde ich prinzipiell ganz cool. Also ich
höre sehr gerne Podcasts und
meine Readinglist in meinem RSS-Reader
ist halt unglaublich lang
und wird selten mal durchgegangen, weil
die sehr viel Anxiety
hervorruft bei mir.
Wie es jeder gute Backlog
tut halt, ne? Ja, ja, aber das ist
gerade im Podcast nicht viel besser, dank
der aktuellen Situation. Gefühlt kommen
jede Woche mindestens 20 neue Folgen in meine
Queue und ich schaffe so alle drei Wochen
drei Folgen aktuell.
Und ja, das ist irgendwie
dieses Ratio nicht sehr gesund.
Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich mal
fünf, sechs, sieben Podcasts
aus meinem Ketchup rausgeworfen.
Ich dachte, die sind bloß...
Ja, ganze Podcasts, die habe ich einfach abbestellt.
Ich dachte, die sind da drin und die waren da drin
unter der Prämisse, ach, das muss ich irgendwann
mal hören.
Und ich habe nicht einmal
eine Folge davon gehört. Auch weil halt momentan
ist eigentlich eine schlechte Zeit für Podcasts, weil
zu Hause Podcasts hören, ohne
Pendeln oder
ohne
lange unterwegs sein auf der Straße,
geht halt nicht so gut.
Absolut.
Obwohl man mittlerweile wahrscheinlich Podcasts hören könnte,
während man in der Schlange vor irgendeinem
Laden steht.
Ich war gestern mal in der Stadt und
dachte, ich gehe mal kurz, hol mir mal
einen Termin bei meinem Friseur.
Und wir waren in der Innenstadt und da waren
diese ganzen Läden, also es waren erstaunlich viele Läden,
waren nicht mehr da, witzigerweise.
Ich wollte mir bei einem mal...
Was heißt, du meinst du mit nicht mehr da? Die haben schon dich gemacht?
Es gab, also das heißt ja schon nicht viele Läden.
Es gab ein, zwei Läden, die in der Dresdner Innenstadt
jetzt zu sind.
Okay, schade.
Und vor allen anderen
Klamottenläden, da standen irgendwie zehn Leute
draußen in der Schlange, weil die immer bloß und so viele Leute
reinlassen. Das war so meine Beobachtung.
Mein erstes Mal Exkursion in die Dresdner
Innenstadt und
die Straßen sind voll
und überall... Ja, es war unerwartet.
Ich war auch vor zwei Wochen das erste Mal wieder in der, also bin da von der Prager Straße einmal runtergelaufen, von der Haltestelle bis zum Hauptbahnhof und einfach mal zu schauen, was so abgeht und weil wir da noch einkaufen gehen wollten. Und es war echt erstaunlich voll. Also da waren super viele Leute, gerade vor den ganzen Läden, also typische Shoppingmeile ist das halt. Und also warum geht man jetzt Klamotten kaufen? Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, gut, du wirst es natürlich auch nicht,
gar nichts mehr machen aktuell,
aber fast zumindest nicht in die Dinge,
die ich aktuell machen möchte.
Aber gut, jedem das Seine an der Stelle.
Bei mir war die Motivation zumindest,
ich habe es Anfang März nicht geschafft,
zum Friseur zu gehen, bevor es nicht mehr ging.
Und bin seitdem nicht beim Friseur gewesen.
Ja, same, seit Dezember nicht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Seit Dezember nicht.
Holy shit.
Aber du hattest wirklich eine komplette Stoppelfrisur vorher.
Ja, ich war sehr kurzhaarig beim Kongress noch.
Das war das letzte Mal, dass ich beim Friseur war, direkt vom Kongress.
Genau, und deswegen dachte ich, muss ich das jetzt endlich mal wieder machen.
Und ähnlich habe ich mir zum Beispiel, ich besitze keine Jacke,
die irgendwie zum Frühling oder Sommer passt.
Ich habe nur viel zu warme Jacken.
Und deswegen dachte ich, ich muss jetzt mal rausgehen
und mir was dünneres besorgen.
Und ich habe nicht geschafft.
Die Jacke setzt ja voraus, dass man rausgehen möchte.
Möchtest du nicht manchmal rausgehen?
Na, möchten schon.
Naja, gut, genug zu dem Thema.
Genau, lass uns das mal abschließen.
Die andere Acquisition, die ich vorher noch ansprechen wollte,
war, dass Giphy jetzt auch von Facebook gekauft wurde.
Was einerseits sehr schade ist,
weil viele Sachen auf Giphy aufbauen.
Also quasi der Gip-Support in jeder zweiten App,
die man so benutzt, baut auf Giphy auf.
Aber zum anderen, ich fand es irgendwie erstaunlich,
dass es noch nicht irgendwie zu so einer Klitsche
wie Facebook gehört hat.
Aber diese Plattform ist auch
so schrecklich. Du kannst die Webseite
halt nicht nutzen. Also du machst die auf und
mein Rechner friert das mal ein, weil
das ist viel zu groß.
Giffy kannst du eigentlich nur per API benutzen, oder?
Oder als Integration? Oh ja.
Ich habe da so eine Mac App, die heißt Jiffy mit J vorne.
Also darf man auch so aussprechen.
Von Sint Rezohus, dem
allbekannten, sehr
sehr produktiven
Entwickler aus der JavaScript, der neuesten
und der hat so eine kleine
Menuball-App, wo du einfach nur GIFs suchen kannst
und rausdragen kannst, überall anders hin.
Finde ich
eigentlich ganz, ganz angenehm. Und was hat das jetzt für einen Effekt,
dass das irgendwie jedes Mal, wenn ich irgendwo ein GIF hinzufüge,
dass dann Facebook
mir Werbung zeigt über das GIF, was ich
da irgendwo hinzugefügt habe oder was? Was hat sich
Facebook dabei gedacht, dass sie GIF wie kaufen?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Der andere
ist ja wahrscheinlich erstmal, dass das Tracking-Pixel nicht mehr
ein 1 Byte, äh nicht 1 Byte,
also möglichst kleines Kilobyte
Pixel ist, sondern Tracking-GIFs
sind halt ein paar MB groß.
Tracking-Givis.
Nee, aber du hast
wahrscheinlich viele Daten, die du darüber sammeln kannst,
warum die das ansonsten haben wollen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es eine große bekannte Plattform ist
und das Einverleiben,
für die es auch Sinn ergibt. Keine Ahnung.
Mehr am Ball der
Zeit bleiben, was Leute auch nutzen.
Aber gab es nicht noch andere Plattformen außer Giphy?
Ich kenne zumindest keine.
Was ist denn da hier? Es gab doch
Imgur oder so ähnlich.
Das sind ja keine, ja,
Imgur ist ja ein generischer Imagehost.
Dann gibt es noch sowas wie, ich glaube,
GiphyCat oder I, also GFYCat
hieß das noch.
Wie hat Giphy überhaupt funktioniert? Wer zum Geier
lädt diese ganzen GIFs hoch?
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwie eine AI, die Filme scannt und dann
irgendwelche Zähnen rausscrapt und da irgendwie,
also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man viele
von diesen Giphy auch generieren kann.
Wenn du einfach die Subtitles nimmst
und der dazu passende
Schnipsel dann immer einfach nur als GIFs
mit Reactions zu passenden Strings zusammenbastelt,
das geht locker. Da kannst du wahrscheinlich gleich
die, vielleicht 90 Prozent der GIF-Usage
erschlagen, die es auf diesem Planeten gibt.
Genau, weil ich hab,
weißt du, was mir bei dem Zusammenhang einfällt,
so als gruseliges Seitenthema,
kennst du, weißt du noch, hatten wir vielleicht schon drüber
geredet, kennst du This Person, das not exist?
Oh ja.
Da gehst du einfach auf irgendeine, da gehst du hin,
lädst das und dann kriegst du ein Bild von einer Person,
das ein komplett legittes Foto sein könnte
und das
existiert aber einfach nicht.
Die haben häufig sehr ähnliche Zähne allerdings.
Ja, manchmal geht's kaputt,
vor allem an Brillen. Da sieht man mal wieder, wie das
neuronale Netz da tatsächlich dann
versucht zusammenzuschieben alles.
Ich hab in letzter Zeit relativ oft auf Twitter gesehen,
die Seite This Person Does Not Exist,
weil diverse Leute versucht haben,
mal ihren Avatar für
eine Woche einfach eine
Frau zu machen und zu schauen, was so die
Twitter-Reactions sind. Ich hätte das gerne als
als API oder sowas.
Aber ich hab dann...
Mit Parametern auch noch, wo du dann so Haarfarbe
einstellen kannst, was du gerade haben möchtest.
Das könnte man doch eigentlich bei
Tinder oder so reintun. Das wäre mal spannend,
was man da für Reaktionen kriegt.
Zumindest
gibt es noch was Neues, was ich irgendwie gesehen habe.
Kennst du diese ganzen Fursonas?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die überhaupt herkommen.
Da gibt es noch
thisfursonadoesnotexist.com
Kannst du dir mal angucken.
Ich schreibe es dir mal in den Chat.
Klunk.
Und das sind einfach
na, Fursona, das ist ein Furry, das ist dann
irgendwie so ein Anime-Tier-Mädchen-Kind-Avatar.
Und die sind auch alle komplett generiert.
Das ist eigentlich die Situation raus.
Sehe ich auch ziemlich viele Leute, da haben das jetzt auf Twitter.
Und da frage ich mich dann immer, gibt es dafür einen Generator?
Ich kann ja den Begriff Fursona nicht bisher.
Oder, ja, ich kenne den Begriff auch nur von der Seite,
this fursona does not exist,
aber offenbar gibt es die auch komplett generiert.
Interessant.
Nee, aber passend zum GIF-Thema noch,
hatte Signal ja jetzt auch GIF-Search
direkt mit in die Messenger implementiert,
was ja ein essentielles Feature für den modernen Messenger.
Genau, man muss sich unbedingt GIFs schicken können.
Ja, also jetzt völlig ernst gemeint, das ist wirklich wichtig.
Und Signal hat das eben vor kurzem eingebaut.
Ich fand das Thema, also das Timing davon auch sehr interessant,
aber das Signal irgendwo mit Facebook im Bett, das wissen wir ja sowieso.
Signal ist mit Facebook im Bett?
Es ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass die mit denen zusammenarbeiten,
wenn Moxi so stolz auf WhatsApps Krypto-Implementation ist.
Und die arbeiten ja wirklich zusammen daran.
Das ist ja kein Geheimnis.
Signal ist schon ein eigenständiges Projekt und Signal hat nichts mit Facebook direkt zu tun.
aber die sind schon close, also im Kontakt, in Regenkontakt.
Also ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn die das jetzt hier für sich völlig überrascht waren,
völlig blindside davon, dass Giphy jetzt nicht mehr eigenständig ist.
Und generell ist der Signal auch nicht daran interessiert, Nutzerdaten prinzipiell herauszugeben.
Und deswegen haben die das auch technisch sehr cool gemacht, diesen GipSearch,
weil die haben hier zwei Sachen beachtet.
Du willst zum einen, wenn du in eine Suchleiste tippst,
schickst du ja quasi jetzt hier
irgendwie die Bounce und Gethwettled User
Input direkt weiter an die Such
API. Genau, also alles, was
ich eingebe, wird halt quasi Schritt für Schritt, meistens
Buchstabe für Buchstabe, ab einem bestimmten
Limit hier losgeschickt.
Wenn ich dann nach Suche hier,
mit dem Beispiel I'm excited, dann wird I geschickt,
dann das M, dann das Leerzeichen, dann immer
als voller String. So macht man sowas ja typischerweise.
Und
sowas wollen die zum einen
nicht GIFI komplett weitergeben, dass die
GIFI API das nicht alles kriegt.
Und zum anderen wollen die quasi einen Proxy dazwischen schieben,
der das alles abfängt.
Aber auch diesem Proxy natürlich nicht die Daten geben,
dass der Proxy weiß, was gesucht wird.
Sprich, die tunneln quasi durch einen TCP-Proxy,
echt ganz witzig,
die ganzen API-Requests an Giphy durch den Signal-Service.
Aber machen das so,
dass der Proxy halt keine Ahnung davon hat,
weil das alles die TLS-Verbindung
quasi vom Client direkt zur Giphy-API läuft.
aber trotzdem getunnelt wird, wie durch
einen VPN-Tunnel, aber direkt durch
die TCP-Relay-Geschichte.
Das finde ich echt
ganz witzig. Ich kann das auch nicht im Detail erklären,
aber die haben das sehr
detailliert in diesem Blogpost, den wir in den Shownotes mit
drin haben, geklärt
und gehen sogar noch so ein bisschen
weiter, dass die...
Also sie haben einfach bloß einen VPN
vor Gifi geknallt.
Genau, sie sind der
VPN.
Und sie wollen natürlich auch nicht, dass du
mitlesen kannst, wenn sie
sich selber als Malicious sehen, was echt eine
Betrachtung ist, was mehr Services
machen sollten, wenn du
dir selber nicht vertrauen kannst, wenn
der Signal Service Malicious wäre,
dann könnte der ja mitlesen.
Und hier auch, da gehen sie sogar noch einen Schritt weiter
und man könnte ja dann sogar so weit gehen,
dass man, wenn man schon die Daten selber nicht lesen kann,
dass man ja zumindest aus der Paketgröße,
aus der Paketgröße, aber aus der
Menge an Daten, die geschickt werden, halt
lesen kann, was ungefähr hier
abgeht und wie gesucht wird
und so weiter. Und
gehen sogar noch so weiter, um dann die
Nachrichten zu padden, die halt weitergeschickt
werden, die durch den Signal Service geschickt werden.
Genau, das sollte man grundsätzlich machen.
Ja, aber was super krass ist, weil sie ja selber die
andere Seite nicht kontrollieren, also sie selber
kontrollieren nicht die Giphy-API, zu der
sie die gepaddeten Nachrichten schicken wollen.
Sprich, die müssten da irgendwie die Nachrichten padden,
aber so, dass sie halt auf der anderen Seite
quasi nicht gepaddet aussehen.
Ja, du könntest es wahrscheinlich machen, indem du
das einfach mit random spaces
auffüllst, die werden dann weggetrimpt von der
Such-API oder sowas?
Das wäre vielleicht eine Möglichkeit,
aber auch, das könnte halt trotzdem zu invaliden
Sachen gehen. Sie machen das technisch cooler,
indem sie quasi einen Teil
der von
warte mal, welche RFC ist das hier?
7, 2, 3, 3. Achso,
Exklusiv HTTP. Exklusiv Teil
des HTTP-RFCs angeschaut
haben, wo drinsteht, dass sie ja
im Header eine Range mitgeben können, welches
die relevanten Bytes sind. Und alles andere
muss halt theoretisch weggeworfen werden.
Und genau darüber machen sie das,
dass sie das halt padden, aber über die Range mit angeben,
was der eigentliche Request ist.
Du kannst bei HTTP, kannst du Nachrichten schicken,
die N groß sind
und dann kannst du im Herder sagen,
nee, aber eigentlich musst du bloß das bis da lesen.
Genau, so habe ich das jetzt zumindest verstanden.
Abgefahren.
Und genau darüber machen sie das.
Und das ist super fancy und super cool.
Technisch finde ich das eine richtig angenehme Implementierung davon.
Und also Hut ab an die
Single-Entwickler immer wieder, was die sich
auf die Art und Weise einfallen lassen, auch was
den Kontaktsharing angeht und so weiter.
Das machen die alles richtig, richtig sauber.
Das finde ich schön, dass die sich die Mühe da machen und man
das vielleicht an anderer Stelle hoffentlich hier
im Matrix-Ecosystem weiterverwerten
kann dieselben Ideen, auf die die da gekommen sind.
Finde ich echt ganz cool.
Abgefahrener Scheiß.
Also haben wir richtig eine saube Implementierung
davon gefunden.
Abgefahrener Scheiß. Was ist eigentlich der nächste
coole Messenger nach Matrix?
Na, hoffentlich keiner.
Jetzt bin ich wieder unglücklich.
Nee, ich habe jetzt in letzter Zeit immer mal wieder,
ich muss sagen, ich leide sehr darunter,
dass ich irgendwie bei Matrix.org bin
und dass das so brechend langsam ist.
Ich bin aber noch zu voll gewesen,
tatsächlich mir irgendwie einen anderen Homeserver zu suchen.
Ich warte noch darauf,
dass es auch hier einen lokalen Homesourced gibt.
Du kannst dir ja einen Job bei der Bundeswehr holen,
dann kriegst du auch bald Matrix.
Oder an der TU Dresden.
Stimmt.
Der TU-Server hat jetzt seit wenigen Tagen
over 9000 User auf dem Matrix-Server.
Wow, over 9000.
Haben sie das auch verblockt oder wie?
Nee, ich habe die Stats gesehen.
Die haben da eine Visualisierung.
Ein hübsches D3-Diagramm.
Aber im Prinzip hält dir ja nichts davon ab,
deinen eigenen Server zu hosten.
Aber ich verstehe auch, dass man natürlich diesen Aufwand
nicht unbedingt betreiben möchte.
Ich meine, für E-Mail mache ich es explizit nicht,
weil ich mir das nicht zutraue.
das Failsafe zu machen.
Und ich gehe fest davon aus, dass wir bald an dem Punkt sind,
jetzt wo die alternativen
Homesulver-Implementierungen immer weiterkommen und Dendrite
auch quasi fast fertig ist oder
quasi funktional ist.
Ich denke immer noch an Schuppen, wenn ich Dendrite
höre. Sorry.
Schuppen? Schuppen, das klingt wie
Schuppen. Aber das heißt Dendron.
Ach so, deswegen.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt
Dendrite, da gibt es doch bestimmt Shampoo gegen.
Eke, ist doch egal.
Das ist ja eher so ein Ding
genauso aus deinem Kopf.
So wie Synapsen sind ja auch, ich weiß nicht,
was Dendrite auf Deutsch
dasselbe Wort ist.
Dendrite ist einfach das deutsche Wort.
Oder Nervenzellen-Cytoplasma-Fortsatz.
Das ist ein guter Name für einen Client.
Der ist garantiert noch frei
im Play Store und im App Store.
Ich gehe fast davon aus, wenn du eine neue
Homeserver-Implementierung schreibst und anfängst,
das Ding Nervenzellen-Cytoplasma-Fortsatz zu nennen,
dann ist das schon sehr nice.
Es wurde ja tatsächlich jetzt auch eine weitere oder ein, zwei neue Implementierungen vorgestellt, die ich mal durchlesen wollte, nämlich weil sie in Rust gebaut sind und das war einmal Melström und wie hieß der andere, der eigentlich viel weiter ist?
Conduit. Ja genau, Conduit,
der der Nachfolger von
Rooma sein soll.
Und
Mellström hat
sich tatsächlich erstaunlich
einfach gelesen, da ist nämlich überhaupt
nichts drin. Die Implementierung
ist hingestellt, der hat
sich hauptsächlich Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie man das
Layout von dem Projekt macht und
wie man die Verteilung macht
und dann hat er so ein bisschen was hingeschrieben
und dann ist bislang aber eigentlich noch gar
nichts da. Das fand ich
und also sehr...
Ich kann sich Conduit echt mal anschauen. Conduit
soll wohl auch recht minimal,
aber deckt halt relativ viel
schon ab. Also ich glaube, der Client-Side-Teil,
also du hast ja prinzipiell für den Matrix-Home-Server
zwei Bestandteile, die relevant
sind. Du hast einmal die Client-API,
die du bereitstellen musst, also neben dem ganzen
interner FU, damit deine
Clients mit dir reden können und du hast die Federation-API,
damit andere Server mit dir reden können,
beziehungsweise auch in die andere Richtung.
Und der Client-Side-Teil
ist, glaube ich, so gut wie fertig. Da ist schon
bis auf ein paar kleine Sachen hier und da,
der größte Teil getan. Und die Federation-API
ist auch gerade am Fertigwerden.
Also Client-Site meinst du, ist alles, was ich brauche,
damit ich ein in sich geschlossenes Matrix
bauen kann.
Genau. Wenn du das Ding aufsetzt, wenn du
eine volle Client-API hast und keine Federation-API,
dann hast du einen Matrix-Server, kannst auf diesem
Server mit allen Leuten reden, mit allen Clients sich
verbinden, aber du hast keine Federation
zwischen verschiedenen Matrix-Servern.
Also diese zwei
Schnittstellen musst du letztendlich implementieren.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie wir das andere Server gemacht haben.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern,
das ist wahrscheinlich bei Telegram,
bei diesem ursprünglichen White Paper,
wo sie beschrieben haben, wie sie ihre eigene Krypto-Rollen
auch beschrieben wurde,
dass die einfach bloß REST machen.
Aber als ich dann über Matrix erfahren habe,
zwei Jahre, drei Jahre später natürlich,
dass die ausschließlich ein REST-Interface implementieren
und im Zweifelsfall Long-Polling machen,
habe ich mir gedacht, what?
Prinzipiell ist das alles einfach eine ganz normale JSON,
das ganze Ding,
bis auf der Sync-Endpoint, den du nutzt,
um Daten,
also um aktuell
im Stand mit den Nachrichten zu bleiben. Und da machen
die, das halt wirklich, über Long-Polling läuft das alles.
Das ist
nur für den Endpoint. Aber da gab es
letztens auch eine kleine witzige Diskussion
zur eigentlichen Idee hinter diesem Sync-Endpoint
im Neo-Raum, wenn ihr Interesse habt.
Hi Helge.
Das ist dann der
Long-Poll, den der Client mit dem
Server offen hält oder zwischen den
Servern? Genau. Nee, das ist nur
Kleinserver. Ja, genau, Kleinserver.
Okay. Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das halt super
hackisch, weil
Rest ist, meinetwegen, Rest ist okay.
Rest ist auch, ich finde es schön,
dass wir diesen Zoo endlich mal hinter uns lassen
und nicht jeder für jeden Scheiß ein neues, komplett
Basic-Protokoll baut. Da kann man gerne
für sowas auch mal Rest nehmen. Ich finde es halt
spannend, weil Matrix dadurch eher, wenn du genau hinguckst,
eher so eine Art Web-Forum ist, weil du da kannst,
du postest halt was hin und dann lädst du
halt die nächsten Nachrichten runter, du hast nicht direkt ein
Realtime-Protokoll mit dem Ding.
Und Long-Polling kannst
du machen, weil es wahrscheinlich
reicht, aber eigentlich ist es nicht geil.
Ne, finde ich auch
suboptimal. Es war wahrscheinlich so
die erste Gedanken,
wahrscheinlich sind ein paar mehr Gedanken reingeflossen, aber es war
so, das geht, das können wir easy umsetzen
und das hat keinerlei Probleme
mit Kompatibilität überall
und deswegen machen wir das.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das nicht eventuell mitzulassen,
es wird wahrscheinlich zu einem gewissen Grad zu der Langsamheit
von Matrix Org zum Beispiel mit beitragen.
Aber es wird sicherlich auch, das klingt jetzt widersprüchlich,
auch dazu beitragen, dass es überhaupt skaliert,
weil du kannst nicht so einen Service aufbauen
und mit jedem Real-Time Messenger die ganze Zeit
eine offene Verbindung halten.
Also zumindest nicht, wenn das mit einer...
Vielleicht kann man das heutzutage, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Doch eigentlich müsste es gehen.
Ich müsste aber auch wissen, was da sinnvolle architektonische Gedanken wären.
Also wie du schon meinst, wenn du jetzt über Websockets gehst
und da ein paar zigtausend Clients dran hängen hast,
dann ist das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so optimal.
Aber keine Ahnung, da habe ich keine Ahnung.
Zumindest hat das den Effekt, dass man, wenn man sich über Matrix hin und her schreibt,
wenn der Server jetzt wie dein eigener sich nicht komplett langweilt,
sondern tatsächlich benutzt wird wie Matrix.org,
dann hast du halt nicht mehr so richtig diesen Realtime-Charakter,
Charakter, weil ich sehe, dass ich eine Nachricht schicke
und dann sitzt die halt noch
eine Minute oder zwei so grau rum
und die ist noch nicht mal quasi
bei dem Gegenüber angekommen.
Ja, das ist schon teilweise
echt nervig. Das ist von der anderen Seite nicht anders.
Also wenn ich von meinem Server aus mit Leuten
auf Matrix-Urg schreibe, dann sehe ich auch oftmals,
dass das echt eine Weile hängt,
was richtig nervig ist, weil du halt weißt, dass das Gegenüber
auch gerade schreibt. Und am Ende hast du dann hier
die fünf Nachrichten, die beide geschrieben haben,
so interspersed, weil
die Server-Systeme aufeinander ihre
Konflikte gelöst haben.
Aber wenn ich jetzt mit anderen Leuten schreibe,
zum Beispiel mit Johannes, der auch
auf dem eigenen Server sitzt und ich auf dem eigenen Server, dann haben wir
quasi wirklich sauberes Real-Time
Instant Communication, weil die Nachrichten
super schnell durchgehen und da überhaupt kein Kontakt
zu dem Matrix-Org-Home-Server.
Ja genau, und deswegen frage ich mich jetzt, liegt das nur daran,
dass der Server so
langsam ist oder dass das Protokoll
irgendwie suboptimal ist? Ich meine, diese ganze
ich synchronisiere die ganze
Zeit, diese ganzen History
Version Trees von meinen
beiden separaten Homeservern,
die quasi ihren
aktuellen letzten Zustand miteinander synchronisieren,
ist ja nicht
ganz billig, so als Operation.
Zumindest nicht, wenn du es halt für jeden Einzelnen
von 10.000 Chatrooms auf
so einem Homeserver machst.
Da ist wahrscheinlich dann das Protokoll, was unten drunter
läuft, gar nicht mehr der
ausschlaggebende Punkt, wenn ich so drüber nachdenke.
Aber wenn du zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, wie
Dendrite, aber Dendrite ist
Go-Implementierung, die sie bauen?
Ja. Wie heißt die aktuelle
Python-Implementierung, die es gibt? Synapse.
Bei Synapse
hatten wir das letzte Mal, und ich lehne mir jetzt hier
aus dem Fenster auch, um so ein bisschen Feedback
aus der Hörerschaft zu bekommen.
Da kannst du natürlich sagen, gut,
das ist mit Twisted gebaut, das macht ein Netzwerk
wahrscheinlich super schnell. Aber wenn
sie zum Beispiel diesen
Solving-Algorithmus,
diesen Merging-Algorithmus, wenn sie
den in Python gebaut haben, dann könnte das auch ein Bottleneck
sein bei der Geschichte.
Und wenn die Nachricht halt ganz lange in so einer Queue auf dem Homeserver liegt und du aber darauf wartest, dass der Server irgendwie für diesen einen Raum oder diesen einen Chatverlauf die Versionen miteinander hier gemerged hat, dann könnte das auch ein Problem sein. Egal, ich fände es mal spannend.
sehr bewusst.
Das ist, glaube ich, sehr, sehr bewusst, sehr schmerzhaft
bewusst, was die Bottlenex und Synapse sind.
Und deswegen gehen sie ja auch mit
Dendrite da in eine völlig andere Richtung.
Zum einen jetzt hier eine andere Sprache,
irgendwas, was kompiliert ist, ist natürlich
der eine Punkt, obwohl Python ja auch so ein bisschen
halb kompiliert ist, aber
der andere Ansatz, was sie auch mit Architektonisch
mit Dendrite auch anders machen, ist, dass die einzelnen
Bestandteile nicht, also es ist nicht eine dicke
Anwendung, die quasi alles macht, sondern du hast
so Worker, die bestimmte Bestandteile
übernehmen, die auch
woanders wo laufen können und die einfach dann
miteinander reden, die aber nicht alle
Bestandteil von dem einen Monolithen sein müssen,
wenn du es nicht möchtest.
Das stimmt. Wer sagt denn, dass das
überhaupt eine Kiste ist, kann man
Synapse?
Synapse, ja.
Synapsen, bleib im Kopf.
Synapsen und dann Dritten.
Da kann man
Synapse auch
verteilt hosten, dass man quasi einfach
35 Instanzen aufmacht, wahrscheinlich.
Das würde sonst überhaupt keinen Sinn geben.
Ich glaube, Synapse gerade eben explizit nicht.
Das war das, was ich im Kopf hatte.
Aber vielleicht kann man das ja doch irgendwie hinschieten
mit hier irgendwelchem Forwarding und wie nennt man das?
Load Balancing.
Vielleicht kriegt man da was hin.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie man die...
Also, ob das letztendlich bloß...
Am Ende hat man vielleicht eine Datenbank
und fünf Synapse-Instanzen oder so.
Das kommt noch dazu,
dass du irgendwie Datenbanken dazwischen hast,
die da auch noch mal synchronisieren musst.
Aber die sind halt selten das Bottleneck.
Also wer weiß, keine Ahnung, auf der Matrix-Org-Scale
ist alles wieder anders.
Genau, begeben wir uns mal von diesem dünnen Eis runter.
Wir haben gerade Python erwähnt.
Ach so, ich wollte noch erzählen,
dass ich letztens in Neo
ein Registration-Feature einbauen wollte.
Und ich will halt auch aktiv dagegen kämpfen,
dass Leute nicht alle sich auf Matrix-Org-Accounts zulegen,
was ja hoffentlich nur eine Frage der Zeit ist.
Ob das nicht mehr so cool ist,
aber du willst halt die Centralization eigentlich nicht haben.
Genauso wie es Jabber.ccc.de gibt,
damit man mehr dezentrale Services hat.
Aber letztendlich hatte jeder bei dem Service letztendlich
einen Account und dann ist es auch wieder
belüht. Genau, deswegen war ich darauf, dass irgendwie Leute
sagen, hier gibt es einen
Matrix-Server, da gibt es einen Matrix-Server, geh doch
zu dem oder geh doch zu dem. Geh doch zu dem von deinem
Local CCC-Chapter
oder geh doch zu dem von deiner
Uni oder von deinem E-Mail-Anbieter.
Exakt das, genau. Und deswegen
wollte ich halt sowas in NIO mit direkt einbauen,
dass du beim Registrieren von neuen Accounts
eine Liste an möglichen Servern hast,
beziehungsweise in der ersten doofen Idee
Shuffle-Button für das Home-Server-Feld, da drückst du drauf,
dann kriegst du einen random Vorschlag und vielleicht kann man das
ein bisschen ausbauen auf hier erstmal
eine Liste, die sortiert vielleicht sogar
nach Server, die die niedrigste Latenz
zu dir gerade haben oder
nach Sprache, die du sprichst, weil letztendlich ist es ja egal,
auf welchem Server du bist, solange die
federieren mit denen, die du magst,
ist halt passend, aber
ich hatte halt UX-mäßig
noch nicht so ganz verstanden, was man da so am geschicktesten
machen könnte. Es gibt Listen von vielen öffentlichen
Synapse-Servern, aber es ist auch immer eine schwierige
Geschichte, weil du nie weißt, von wem
werden die gehostet? Was für Garantien
haben die überhaupt? Weil du wirst ja schon, dass das
nicht irgendwann einfach nach drei Wochen wieder abgeschaltet
wird. Wie gut ist überhaupt die
Migration-Story?
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie meine ganzen Chaträume,
die ich bereits auf Matrix.org habe,
kann ich die irgendwie rübernehmen und sagen, ich bin ab jetzt
nicht mehr hier, sondern dort?
Das ist ja auch noch ein Problem bei sowas.
Also Migration geht aktuell,
soweit ich das weiß, gar nicht.
Du kannst den Raum nochmal mit deinem neuen Account
joinen, aber dann hast du die History
von allem, was da vorher geschrieben wurde
überhaupt? Wenn es im Encrypted-Fall
glaube tatsächlich nicht. Also das Problem
hatte ich, ich hatte das, genauso habe ich das gemacht mit
den meisten Chats, als ich auf meinen Server umgezogen bin
vom Matrix.org weg, dass ich einfach
meinen neuen User da reingeinvited
habe in die ganzen privaten Konversationen
und also
Räume logisch, klar, öffentlich, aber aus den
privaten DMs, neuen User
eingeinvited und mit dem Alpen dann einfach rausgegangen
bin. Aber die History war dann halt
für mich und das fand ich dann auch
Quatsch. Das ist dann schmerzhaft, da denkst du
das ist aber auch einer der Gründe,
warum ich das nicht unbedingt
bislang umziehen wollte.
Geh auf fairydust.space,
das ist der Chaos-Server. Und der ist immer
auf dem Department of Ping, was so ein Teil
vom Disregion Matrix ist, wo die schnellsten
Server immer aufgelistet werden, die fünf schnellsten.
Ist ja immer ganz oben, seitdem es den gibt.
fairydust.space
Genau, ist auch eine
coole Domain.
Was ist eigentlich, wie häufig benutzt du
eigentlich noch
ich weiß nicht, wie man Ferry schreibt.
F-A-I-R-Y.
Wie häufig benutzt du eigentlich noch
Mastodon?
Selten.
Es ist halt tatsächlich wieder öfter, weil ich
die App auf meinem
Home Screen wieder entdeckt habe, auf meinem Mobilgerät,
die ich sehr gerne nutze, weil die sehr schick ist.
Aber ansonsten ist es seit dem Hype
vor, keine Ahnung, zwei Jahren oder wann das war,
echt ziemlich eingeschlafen
wieder. Weil ich mir auch gerade überlegt habe,
die haben ja das gleiche Problem, oder beziehungsweise
also das gleiche Angebot, du gehst auf irgendeine Seite
oder es gibt so Hub-Seiten, die dir dann
unterschiedliche Hoster oder Pods vorschlagen,
wo so ein Mastodon läuft.
Ich habe bei mir selbst
gemerkt, dass ich es gar nicht so aktiv nutze, weil ich
dort nur halt
ein ganz kleines Subset von der
gleichen Community, die ich auf Twitter habe,
so finde. Da lasse ich mir
Cross-Posting, könnte man auch machen, aber
mache ich viel zu selten. Könnte man
diese, könnte man Mastodon und
Matrix gemeinsam ausrollen, das wäre ja fast
sinnvoll, dass man auf der gleichen Ecke,
wo man seinen Mastodon-Account hat, auch einen Matrix-Account
hat.
Und dann lässt du wieder
eigentlich mal selber machen.
Niemand hält die Chaos.Social-Leute
davon ab, noch einen Matrix-Server da drauf zu hosten.
Könnte man
problemlos tun. Hat nichts
miteinander zu tun. Matrix ist
kein Activity-Pub. Das ist was
völlig eigenständiges an der Stelle.
Aber könnte man theoretisch vielleicht sogar
adaptieren, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Obwohl es technisch gar nicht so weit auseinander ist, wenn du mal
nachdenkst, ne?
Die Grundidee ist sehr ähnlich.
Vielleicht könnte man einen Adapter für Activity
Pub für Matrix schreiben. Zumindest, also
in Matrix Dinge
aus Mastodon
oder aus anderen, aus GNU Social oder was auch
immer zu lesen und zu mit interagieren,
stelle ich mir easier vor, als in die andere Richtung zu gehen.
Aber vielleicht pollutest du dann einfach
das Ecosystem, keine Ahnung,
weiß ich nicht. Aber es ist ja
eigentlich nicht ganz so kompatibel und das Gleiche.
Nee,
Nee, ist schon gut.
Aber man könnte sich so, was ist denn so ein Spaß?
Das wäre mal eine Fingerübung für jemanden,
der das erste Mal irgendwie so eine Integration bauen möchte für Matrix,
dass du sagst, hier, subscribe mich mal auf diesem Hashtag.
Oder auf diesem Peertube-Account.
Genau, oder auf diesem Peertube-Account.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich wollte vorhin schon sagen,
lass uns mal von diesem dünnen Eis runtergehen,
aber du hast uns dann von dem dünnen Eis
dann doch wieder auf irgendwie festeres Territorium gebracht.
Wir haben ganz kurz über Python geredet.
hast du gesehen, dass der letzte
Python 2 Release gemacht wurde?
Nein, ist es soweit?
Es ist soweit, Python 2 ist jetzt
tot.
Holy shit.
Das ist zugegebenermaßen schon
einen Monat her wieder, aber ich
habe es nach der letzten Folge gesehen.
C-Python Code Developers are
pleased to announce the immediate
availability of Python
2718.
Python 2718 is the last Python 2.7
release and is therefore the last Python 2.
Release. It is time for the C-Python
Community to say a fun but firm
farewell to Python 2.
Download this unique
commemorative Python Release.
Und ich finde es
auf der einen Seite überraschend,
dass sie
2020 immer noch einen Python 2
Release machen. Ich finde es aber auch gut, dass sie
irgendwie sagen, so jetzt ist Schluss.
Stellt gefälligst
endlich eure Software auf Python 3
um.
Python ist irgendwie aus dieser
Umstellungsphase nie
so richtig rausgekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich habe schon lange nichts mehr davon gehört,
dass es irgendwie Software gibt, die nur noch auf Python 2
läuft, bitte benutzt kein Python 3 dafür
oder sowas. Aber das war ja wirklich ein
großes Problem von Python jahrelang.
Ja,
ist endlich mal an der Zeit, dass das
passiert. Ich finde es auch schön, dass es ein
finales Release gibt. Das ist besser, als einfach zu sagen,
das war übrigens das letzte Release, sondern
das hier ist jetzt das finale Release.
das ist so ein bisschen wie
Netscape, die irgendwie zehn Jahre später dann
mit Netscape Navigator
4.8 rausgekommen
waren, so zehn Jahre nach
Netscape Navigator 4.7.
Aber das ist so das Problem
von Scriptingsprachen.
Du kannst dir halt schlecht,
kannst dir halt schlecht, gerade wenn es
eine richtig, wenn es halt sowas wie Python ist,
ist es halt sehr schwer zu sagen,
modernisier das mal, weil du kannst
jederzeit in einen Codepfad reinrennen,
der plötzlich nicht mehr gut funktioniert in deinem Ding.
Ja, stimmt.
In deiner neuen Sprache.
Das ist das Problem an der Stelle,
dass sowas halt interpretiert wird.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber ja, aber schön,
dass es ein Ende findet.
Farewell Python 2,
Long live Python 3.
Python 2.
Python.
Na, sonst müsstest du Python 2 sagen.
Würdest du Python sagen?
Nee, da schüttelt es einer.
Und wann kann ich endlich Python 3
nicht mehr schreiben in meinem Terminal, sondern einfach nur
direkt Python?
Aber ist
Python 3 nicht schon lange das default?
Bei mir nicht.
Würde mich arg wundern, aber das ist eher
so ein Apple-Ding.
Python-Version
2717.
Immerhin das
fast aktuellste. Achso, sorry, du bist
auf Mac, ich bin auf Arch Linux, da ist schon
seit Jahren Python 3. Ja, Arch zählt nicht.
Also, wer auf Arch Linux ist,
der kriegt ja eh aktuelle Sachen.
Was ist mit den ganzen Debian-Usern da draußen?
Wann kriegen die mit, dass es überhaupt Python 3 gibt?
Wahrscheinlich, sobald es aus Testing raus ist,
irgendwann in zehn Jahren oder so.
In Testing ist es schon drin? Okay.
Debian-Testing ist ja so das, naja, weiß ich nicht.
Ich mag Debian-Testing, aber ich finde Debian,
also ich finde witzig, wenn Leute auf Debian-Stable hängen.
Das amüsiert mich immer.
Ja, das ist ja Anwendungsfälle.
Man will ja nicht alles administrieren müssen, aber...
Also ich verstehe es nicht, warum. Für Desklobs verstehe ich es nicht, aber zum Beispiel dieser Rust-Playground wurde in der Webseite irgendwie Code hacken und dann irgendwo kompilieren kannst. Der war auf Arch Linux gehostet und der war irgendwann mal kaputt, weil es ein Breaking-Update in Arch Linux gab.
Und da habe ich mir in dem Moment gedacht, ich verstehe nicht, warum ein Service auf Arch Linux host kann, das wäre mir viel zu viel arbeiten. Also mein Arch Linux funktioniert auch nur und es funktioniert gut, weil ich einfach jeden Tag immer mal ein Update fahre und die ganze Zeit die Pakete aktuell halte, dann geht das.
Aber je nachdem, was du hast, steht auf der Webseite Manual Intervention Required.
Da musst du dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mal dein Bildsystem austauschen, dein Init-System austauschen oder sowas.
Deswegen würde ich das niemals für so einen Service nehmen.
Obwohl das wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch Quark ist, weil die meisten von solchen Sachen
mittlerweile eh auf irgendwelchen Docker-Containern basieren.
Würde ich mir trotzdem nicht zu tun.
Also ich hätte eine Heidenangst dafür,
so was Volatiles wie ein Archie-Luxer-Space-System
für mein Server anzunutzen,
wo ich tendenziell, auch wenn ich es häufiger müsste,
aber tendenziell eher seltener Updates fahre
als auf meinem Desktop-System.
Ja, es ist eigentlich Quark.
Vor allem, wo du wirklich alles, was High-Level ist,
mittlerweile einfach oben drüber in Form von Containern laufen lässt.
Dementsprechend kannst du die auch wesentlich schneller ausrollen.
Eigentlich, ja.
Eigentlich habe ich so ein Container im Server-Bereich
so ein bisschen den Paketmanager gekillt.
Das musste ich nicht mehr auf deiner
Kiste einloggen, um die zu updaten,
sondern du hast einfach da irgendwie
was Minimales laufen und rollst einfach
immer neu.
Ja, same.
Ich freue mich immer, wenn es ein Docker-Update dann gibt,
weil dann sehe ich, dass das alles mal kurz neu
gestartet wird, aber...
Auf jeden Fall.
So, was haben wir denn noch auf unserer Liste?
Ich habe hier noch
geschrieben, dass die GitHub-Universe
war letztens. GitHub's
jährliche Kino,
ist es jährlich? Ich glaube schon.
Wo sie halt neue Sachen vorstellen.
Genau. Und da haben sie
unter anderem ein cooles Feature vorgestellt,
das sich Codespaces nennt.
Ist aktuell noch in der
Early Access Beta
beschränkt. Wir haben, glaube ich,
beide noch keinen Zugriff darauf. Aber die Idee
dahinter ist, dass du einfach direkt
in dem Repo
quasi einen Editor öffnen kannst.
Und das Ganze ist nicht nur einfach so ein Ace
oder so, so wie aktuell,
sondern ein vollwertiger Editor mit Ahnung von deinem Code
und Completion und auch Debugging-Möglichkeiten.
Und du kannst es starten und so.
Also es ist ein vollwertiges Visual Studio Code, was da läuft.
Sie haben ja...
Ist es wirklich Visual Studio Code basiert?
Das ist direkt ein VS Code, was da läuft.
Also ich meine, sie haben ja wirklich mittlerweile
fast alles in GitHub drin, was man dafür braucht.
Also ich fände es schon spannend,
wenn du irgendeine Code-Datei aufmachst,
dass du dann bereits da dran auf Symbole klicken kannst.
und dann...
Aber nur in komischen Sprachen, die keiner nutzen möchte.
Sowas wie TypeScript und so.
Ja, das sind halt die, wo der Compiler
wahrscheinlich dann genauso gut bei denen läuft.
Natürlich
fälligst du da bei einem Subset von Sprachen an.
Und dann haben sie
natürlich mit ihren Actions haben sie bereits die Möglichkeit
irgendwie, beziehungsweise haben sie jetzt
andere CI-Anbieter quasi
vollständig verdrängt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie jetzt, Travis,
dazu steht, dass
jetzt Leute mehr und mehr eigentlich über GitHub-Actions
und
dementsprechend ist das jetzt glaube ich einfach der nächste
konsequente Schritt, wo ich es ein bisschen
krass finde, also GitHub wird dadurch wirklich ganz
schön überladen an Funktionalität, ich
finde es nicht, was ein bisschen krass ist, aber
geil ist es schon irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob es
Leute für
regelmäßige
Arbeit nutzen würden.
Das war deine Katze?
Ja, Katze macht
Geräusche im Hintergrund.
Könntest du dir vorstellen, dass du es für regelmäßig
gearbeitet hast?
Also für mich persönlich nicht,
weil das halt nicht das Ecosystem
abdeckt, was ich bräuchte, im Sinne von
Darwin-Plattformen,
aber ich meine, GitHub Actions
können ja macOS CI
und die nutze ich auch sehr häufig als CI
für quasi alle meine Swift-Packages.
Da nutze ich das so darüber.
Also prinzipiell arbeitet man ja in so
einem System dann und
ein gemeinsamer Bekannter von uns versucht gerade
auch
einem iPad eine iOS-App
zu schreiben, nur auf der Basis
von GitHub-Containern.
Also da quasi
einen macOS-Container zu nutzen und darauf
das App-Signing zu machen und alles.
Und hat da ein bisschen Spaß mit
das gerade einzurichten.
Aber ich weiß nicht, inwiefern er damit schon
erfolgreich war.
Abgefahren.
Ja, ich meine,
auf der einen Seite cool, dass es existiert.
Und ich finde es den logischen nächsten Schritt
von Microsoft, sowas einzubauen.
aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch
scary, dass
GitHub immer mehr die Plattform ist, wo man eigentlich
am Ende gar nichts anderes braucht
und alles auf Microsoft Services aufbaut
Ja, tatsächlich, also ich
finde es auf der einen Seite cool, was
Microsoft quasi alles unter seine Schirmherrschaft
holt, auf der einen Seite
weil man sich auch
also gerade über NPM und GitHub hat man sich
zu einem gewissen Punkt auch immer mal ganz kurz Sorgen gemacht
wie es damit so weitergeht
aber auf der anderen Seite verlässt du dich
halt jetzt permanent auf den Goodwill von dieser
Firma. Da haben wahrscheinlich
viele Amerikaner weniger ein Problem
mit, aber es ist schon ein bisschen
bedenklich.
Ja, auf Hacker News wird immer
so oft so schön auseinandergezerrt.
Ich weiß schon mal kurz, ob ich den
Kommentar direkt kurz kriege.
Shit, wo war das?
Riot, warum kannst du nicht suchen?
Du benutzt selber noch Riot auf macOS?
Es gibt ja nichts Besseres.
Kannst du Neo dann eigentlich auch auf macOS benutzen,
wenn du es mit SwiftUI baust?
Hoffe ich ja.
Also aktuell geht es noch nicht,
weil das Adobe Matrix iOS SDK nicht für macOS sich bauen lässt.
Nicht mehr. Früher ging das mal.
aktuell haben sie verkackt und auch die Catalyst-Version
geht nicht mehr.
Aber sie
ist auf jeden Fall geplant.
Ich habe es gerade gefunden.
Also Microsoft hat ja
letztens ein paar generelle Dinge angekündigt.
Unter anderem, wir kommen auch später nochmal kurz darauf zu sprechen.
Aber ich fand sehr interessant
ein Kommentar auf Hacker News dazu.
Der meinte
die Person, it appears that Microsoft has now
initiated the extend phase of their
classic embrace, extend, extinguish
playbook. The key is that
Proprietary Microsoft-Sspecific API.
Achso, hier geht es gerade um was anderes.
Hier geht es gerade um DirectX-Support für Linux,
was sie ja auch angekündigt haben.
What?
Dass sie halt jetzt quasi so in diesem Teil ihrer Phase sind,
was sie halt anscheinend schon öfter durchlaufen haben
für diverse Produkte und aktuell vielleicht ganz cool wirken
und fancy und new shit,
aber demnächst alles wieder kaputt machen.
Das wird sich zeigen.
Das ist so ein Playbook, nach dem nicht nur Microsoft arbeitet,
nach dem arbeiten auch andere große Firmen, leider.
Na klar, du musst
irgendwie in den Markt eindringen und das machst du
indem du dich beliebt machst und
jetzt haben sie so viel Macht, dass sie jetzt
quasi ihre Policies durchsetzen können.
Das ist eigentlich krass, wie eigentlich
Firmen wie Staaten agieren,
so ein bisschen. Jetzt haben sie sich irgendwie
in dem Territorium
ein Beachhead errichtet
und jetzt können sie demnächst die Kontrolle
übernehmen. Das ist jetzt alles ein bisschen
verschwörungstheoretisch, aber
was da als nächstes passiert.
Es gab ja wirklich eine große Welle von Leuten,
die gesagt haben, so, GitHub ist jetzt
vorbei, ich gehe jetzt woanders hin, wenn das
Microsoft gehört, tschüss.
Ich kann das auch voll verstehen. Also für öffentliche Sachen
finde ich GitHub eine tolle Plattform nach wie vor,
aber für private Sachen, willst du die wirklich auf
Microsoft-Servern hosten?
Willst du Microsoft den Zugang
zu deinen privaten Projekten geben?
Ich hatte auch auf GitHub
private Repos liegen, die
auf GitHub auch ein paar private
Repos liegen, die die Secrets von mir
beinhalten. Also die kann
theoretisch, die konnte vorher
jeder GitHub-Mitarbeiter an sich abusen,
aber jetzt liegen die bei Microsoft.
Und das sind jetzt keine Secrets, die irgendwo
schlimmeserend sind. Das sind eher so Credentials
für ein, zwei
Systeme von mir, aber nichts
irgendwo Kritisches, nichts, wo man eine große Abuse treiben könnte,
aber das sind halt trotzdem Zugangsdaten.
Also sowas habe ich grundsätzlich vorher
nicht gemacht. Erstens, weil ich keinen Zugang zu
GitHub hatte, wo ich hätte irgendwelche
privaten Repos anlegen können. Das heißt,
es ist mittlerweile anders. Jetzt mache ich ab und zu mal ein privates
Repo. Ich finde gerade überhaupt nichts mehr von dir.
Es kommt gerade nichts mehr an.
Kleiner Moment.
So, Band läuft. Wir wurden jetzt eine Weile
unterbrochen, weil bei Köln
offenbar jemand das Internet,
das WLAN-Kabel angebaggert hat.
Also fühlt sich zumindest an. Es ist echt irgendwie
ein bisschen arg bekloppt hier gerade. Der Router
blinkt nur, ist komplett die Verbindung weg.
der hat überhaupt keinen Uplink. Ich sag's dir,
das nächste Mal nehmen wir einfach wieder bei mir auf und dann mit der
Maske im Gesicht. Mal schauen, wie das funktioniert.
Mein Handy liegt jetzt gerade da hinten,
wo ich hinzeige, im Fenster
und macht jetzt hier, damit es bestmöglich
einen Empfang hat und macht jetzt Tethern
hier zum Rechner.
Hast du bis dahin ein Lightning-Kabel
liegen oder wie?
Da liegt tatsächlich da hinten eine Steckdose am Kabel.
Obwohl es wird irgendwie nicht von einer Katze aus der Fensterbank
geschmissen oder sowas.
Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Wir waren bei GitHub.
Du wolltest noch was zu
Secrets
sagen vielleicht?
Ja, vielleicht um die ganze Sache ein bisschen abzurunden,
sonst kriege ich das hier nie rund.
Also ich habe bei GitHub noch nie
irgendwas
Sensibles hochgeladen.
Ja, nee, sensibel würde ich
jetzt auch nicht sagen, aber Dinge, die halt theoretisch
abusebar sein könnten.
Ja, also ich meine, dafür gibt es ja extra Bots,
die GitHub durchsuchen
nach Sachen,
die nach Keys aussehen.
Also AWS-Credentials würde ich niemals irgendwie in GitHub pushen,
ganz bestimmt nicht.
Dafür gibt es auch nichts, was automatisiert abusbar ist,
sondern musstest du halt wirklich in meinem Fall rangehen,
als Mensch draufschauen und wissen, wo du damit hingehst.
Aber ja, es sind halt Configs für zwei, drei Services.
Obwohl sich mir da spontan jetzt die Frage stellt,
wie macht man das, weil ich es einfach noch nicht gemacht habe,
wie macht man das, wenn man zum Beispiel aus einer GitHub-Action raus
irgendwas deployen möchte und dafür
genau irgendwo Credentials hinterlegen muss.
Wie macht man das? Die legst du in die GitHub Secrets.
Die liegen halt auch quasi bei Microsoft auf Servern,
aber die sind halt nicht im Repo auslesbar.
Sind halt quasi Endvariablen,
die nicht für Nutzer einnützbar sind.
Da fällt mir was ein, was ich eigentlich ansprechen wollte.
Und zwar habe ich jetzt gesehen, dass das Tokyo-Projekt,
diese asynchrone Rust Runtime,
die benutzen auf
GitHub jetzt Discussions
und da ist mir zum ersten Mal aufgefallen, dass GitHub
ja auch eine Forumsfunktion hat. Hast du dir das mal angeguckt?
Stimmt, die haben das.
Habe ich noch nie wirklich benutzt.
Hin und wieder stopperte man mal darüber.
Super weird, finde ich das.
Auf jeden Fall.
Du findest es weird?
Ich finde es weird.
GitHub hat jetzt seine eigene CI.
Es hat jetzt einen Package Manager.
Es hat demnächst einen Editor, den du mit ausprobieren kannst.
Es hat seine eigene Issues.
Und Wiki hat es schon lange gehabt.
Jetzt hat es halt Discussions noch dazu.
Wenn du das erweiterte
Ecosystem noch siehst und deine Anwendung direkt
auf Azure deployst und
auf einem Windows-Laptop arbeitest, dann bleibst du halt komplett
in dem Ecosystem von Microsoft.
Irgendwie hat es jetzt also
alles, was Sourceforge geboten
hat, geht das mittlerweile auch an
und noch mehr.
Jetzt müssen sie nur noch
deine Downloads patchen
mit Werbung oder so.
Ja, das ist der nächste Schritt.
Ja, wenn wir schon bei Microsoft sind, die hatten ja auch vorgestern oder irgendwann in den letzten, nee, Anfang der Woche, glaube ich, die Microsoft Build, glaube ich so heißt das, ich bestecke ja nicht so ganz drin, wo die auch ihre Konferenz haben und Dinge announced haben, haufenweise Sachen.
Unter anderem das von mir vorhin erwähnte DirectX für Linux, was super interessant ist.
Ich dachte erst, du meinst ActiveX für Linux, das wäre nochmal super.
Nee, nee, nee, das wäre noch schlimmer.
Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was verhindert, dass
bislang den
neuen Internet Explorer auf Chrome-Basis,
äh, sorry, Edge, auf Chrome-Basis
auf Linux rausbringen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da
bereits Builds gibt, aber
ja, red weiter, DirectX
für Linux.
Genau, es ist irgendwie so ein Hype,
so ein Ding, also das ist
für WSL Dinge
auf Windows-Plattformen.
Ich habe übrigens letztens gelernt, dass WSL
WSL heißt, aus Gründen,
also ich weiß nicht immer nur ein dummer Name,
Das Windows Subsystem for Linux.
Achso, das klingt falsch rum.
Ja, eben. Genau, es ist eigentlich auch falsch rum.
Und das wissen die auch.
Aber Linux Subsystem for Windows wäre korrekterweise passender Name.
Aber die dürften kein Projekt haben,
was Linux als erstes Wort hat aus Trademark-Gründen.
Deswegen haben sie es genau umgedreht, benannt.
Das ist Windows Subsystem for Linux.
Naja.
Naja, es ist ein Windows Subsystem.
Und wofür ist es da?
Damit du Linux machen kannst.
Wenn das so rumnimmst, ergibt es fast.
das Vor ist ein bisschen kaputt an der Stelle, aber ja,
stimme ich dir zu. Also worum kann man es auch deuten.
Das hat
auf jeden Fall laut Kommentaren
zumindest ein paar Probleme,
aus Gründen, wer sich darum jetzt kümmern darf
und wer das supporten darf und wahrscheinlich nicht tun
wird, aber abseits davon
haben die auch noch ein paar andere Sachen rausgebracht.
Was ich vor allem interessant fand, ist
das sogenannte
Multi-Plattform-App-UI-Projekt,
auch MAUI abgekürzt.
MAUI.
Was die
Quasi dieselbe Idee verfolgt wie SwiftUI an der Stelle,
bloß halt wirklich plattformübergreifend,
dass du ein plattformagnostisches UI-Framework hast,
was auf der jeweiligen Plattform dementsprechend korrekt angezeigt wird.
In dem Fall für C-Sharp.
Also an sich eine coole Idee.
Und Support scheint wohl da zu sein für quasi alle bekannten Plattformen.
Finde ich auch sehr krass.
Also von Windows zu iOS zu Android zu macOS zu anderen Sachen sogar noch.
Also beeindruckend.
auf Linux. Würde ich zeigen, inwiefern das dann
benutzt wird, wirklich? Nice.
Das bleibt halt im C-Sharp-Ecosystem, aber
das ist ja auch relativ populär. Ja, aber gleichzeitig
kannst du jetzt mit diesem
Windows-Subsystem für Linux mittlerweile
vollständige UI-Gnom-Anwendungen
auf Windows laufen lassen.
Oha. Das
war auch neulich
in, hab ich neulich auch
gelesen. Okay,
cool. Also es muss nicht mehr explizit
für Windows gepackaged sein, oder was?
Da würde
aber es ist wohl prinzipiell seit der letzten Version von diesem WSL möglich,
ganze GUI-Anwendungen zu starten.
Krass. Okay. Nicht schlecht.
Oder ganze GNOME-Anwendungen zu starten,
wenn es nicht GUI-Anwendungen vorher sogar schon gab.
Aber irgendwas ist da jetzt dazu gekommen,
was es möglich macht, ganze GNOME-Anwendungen zu starten.
Krass.
Die eine andere Sache, die wir noch angekündigt hatten,
war, also neben anderen, ich habe nicht die volle Liste gelesen,
bloß die paar Sachen, über die ich gestolpert bin,
Das war jetzt der Windows Package Manager,
ein offizieller Package Manager für Windows von Microsoft.
Stimmt, ja.
Und was ich super cool daran finde,
ist, dass die Bibliothek dahinter an verfügbaren Paketen
auch einfach nur, genauso wie bei Homebrew letztendlich gehandhabt wird,
ist einfach nur ein GitHub-Repo, wo die drin liegen.
Und das sind einfach ein paar Jammel-Dateien mit den Spezifikationen.
Die sind auch relativ kurz und sehr lesbar gehalten.
Also da ist nicht viel mehr dabei, neben ein paar Metadaten.
Aber da liegt nur der Index drin.
Ja, also der Index selber ist das nur genau.
Weil das macht Cargo auch.
Auf die Art und Weise.
Die haben einfach den Index in GitHub.
Ich dachte, bei Cargo ist es
explizit kein Git-Repo, aber vielleicht bin ich da
falsch informiert.
Nee, also der Index zumindest
ist ein Git-Repo.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du da als Kunde, als Benutzer
direkt selber hingehst
oder ob sie das einfach von dem Service aus
benutzen, aber es gibt definitiv ein
Crates-Index-Repo irgendwo.
Vielleicht ist das auch nicht mehr aktuell.
Da gibt es sicherlich auch Sinn, um das so zu versionieren.
War früher immer ganz witzig,
weil ich kenne das hauptsächlich von Homebrew und von CocoaPods,
diesem alten Package Manager für iOS,
die das eben so gelöst haben.
Und CocoaPods hat das Specs-Repo,
so hieß das dann immer, auf GitHub liegen gehabt.
Und das hatte halt den witzigen Nebeneffekt,
dass das so viel Traffic erzeugt hat,
dass GitHub irgendwann halt explizit zwei eigene Systeme hat,
nur für dieses eine Repo.
Zwei eigene Rechner.
Hatten die dann die Pakete dort gehostet
oder hatten die auch bloß den Index?
Nee, nur die Specs.
Ach krass, damit haben sie trotzdem noch genug Traffic produziert dafür.
Also es war erstaunlich.
Also GitHub hat sich da öfter mal in die Issues reingesetzt
und eigene PRs gemacht,
um das Ganze ein bisschen sauberer zu strukturieren,
weil sie halt merken, was genau die Bottlenecks waren.
Ich glaube, das eine Problem war irgendwie,
dass die da alle im Route, glaube ich, anfangs rumlagen oder so.
Und das wollten die dann optimieren,
weil das irgendwie für Git besser lief,
wenn da in einzelnen Subtory-Vectories aufgesplittet war.
Und haben da halt selber mit PRs gemacht
und haben halt aber auch offen beteuert mit,
wir werden das weiter hosten.
Wir sind unserer Mission bewusst,
das hier kostenlos hosten zu wollen,
bis in alle Ewigkeit.
Aber das erzeugt halt schon erstaunlich viel Last bei uns.
Wir würden das gerne ein bisschen optimieren, wenn möglich.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade den Blogpost gefunden,
ich weiß nicht, ob du den schon verlinkt hast,
zum Thema Multiplattform-App-UI.
Die sind beide schon drin.
Genau.
Und du siehst hier in dem Git-Repo
tatsächlich so einen Haufen von,
also das sind tonnenweise Pakete, die da alle
übereinander legen, das ist ein bisschen unübersichtlich, aber du hast
ganz viel so Platform.Android.Foundations
und Platform.Android.So und so
und es gibt halt auch
Platform macOS, Platform Tizen,
Platform WPS, Platform
iOS und Platform GTK.
Dementsprechend
vielleicht erschlagen die jetzt
damit wirklich alles.
Ja.
Also es ist erstaunlich viel Kram mit drin.
Finde ich sehr cool.
Also, wird sich zeigen. Vielleicht ist das der Nachfolger
von Xamarin oder vielleicht ist Xamarin
jetzt mit das.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz im Klaren, wie das alles zusammenhängt.
Aber an sich finde ich es mega cool.
Ja, obwohl, es gab doch
schon vor ein, zwei Jahren, war Xamarin
auch ein Microsoft-Projekt oder so?
Also, die wurden zumindest gekauft.
Ich glaube ursprünglich nicht, aber die wurden dann gekauft.
Es gab doch bereits einmal einen Ansatz von Microsoft,
wo sie gesagt haben, hier, guck mal, mit dem Ding könnt ihr jetzt
eine App bauen, die dann auf iOS
und Android funktioniert und auf
Windows-Telefon.
und da gab es eigentlich
einen Aufschrei, hauptsächlich von App-Entwicklern,
die gesagt haben, wir wollen das nicht,
weil unsere Industrie
funktioniert so, dass wir, wenn wir gebeten
werden, eine App zu bauen, dann bauen wir eine App für iOS
und dann bauen wir eine App für Android
und das sind unsere Arbeitsplätze,
ihr könnt auch nicht einfach machen, dass man nur noch eine App bauen muss.
Das ist ein Schwarz.
Auch mit dem Argument
zu kommen, finde ich ein bisschen harmselig.
So, ihr nehmt meinen Arbeitsplatz
weg.
Naja, aber ich meine, wenn
auf dich jetzt einer zukommt und sagt,
bau mir mal was, keine Ahnung,
irgendwas, ÖPNV
mit Fahrkarten oder sowas,
aber du kannst es nicht
machen, dass das nur auf iOS läuft oder
dass du zwei Apps bauen musst, eine für iOS
und eine für Android. Kannst du das mal bitte damit machen,
damit das einfach überall funktioniert?
Da denkst du ja auch so, ach scheiße, da kann ich gar kein
SwiftUI mehr machen.
Gut, es gibt immer verschiedene Anforderungen
und wenn die Anforderung an der Stelle ist,
ich als Personal, wenn die
Anforderung an der Stelle ist, ich alleine
muss das machen in Zeit X
und bestenfalls halt das
sinnvoll nutzen, dann werde ich hier nicht versuchen, zwei native
Projekte aufzuziehen. Es sei denn, es ergibt für das Projekt
halt wirklich Sinn. Wenn das Projekt
native Sachen erforderlich macht,
dann würde ich es natürlich dementsprechend versuchen.
Aber wenn es das nicht braucht, dann ist vielleicht am Ende
bloß hier dieses typische Beispiel von
Minimal-App, was einfach nur eine JSON-Ziehung
und eine Liste von Elementen anzeigt.
Dann kannst du dafür nutzen, was du möchtest
an Cross-Plattform-Fuhr. Ob das jetzt React Native,
Flutter oder Xamarin ist, dann machst du
nur das Leben einfacher.
Und das hat alles schon eine Daseinsberechtigung,
finde ich. Und ich will jetzt nicht so
elitär dahergehen. Nur
nativ ist das einzig Wahre. Aber
es ist auch nicht so, als ob nativ sterben sollte.
Deswegen hat es genauso viele Anwendungsfälle.
Es liest sich
auf jeden Fall schon mal ziemlich schick,
wie sie es hier schreiben.
Ist natürlich C-Sharp, aber
C-Sharp ist auch
eine tolle Sprache. Die haben Async-Await
und cooles Typsystem und so.
Die haben Async-Await vor allem
pioniert.
Ja.
Naja, mal gucken.
Wie scharpt ist das, was Java hätte sein sollen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe es von einem Freund gehört.
Finde ich eine schöne Aussage.
Oje.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es für mich wieder
ein Ding mehr, wo ich mir denke,
oh Gott, Mobile ist so viele unterschiedliche
Sachen, die du da machen musst, um irgendwie
Mobile-Apps bauen zu können.
Nein, musst du ja nicht. Es gibt ja bloß viele
Optionen und letztendlich ist es Rille,
welche du davon nimmst, solange du dich dafür entscheidest
und das für dich halt begründen kannst,
warum du das, also
für dich eine Entscheidung getroffen hast, passt das ja.
Ich habe nichts dagegen,
wenn jemand ein React Native in der App baut.
Ich habe was dagegen, wenn jemand versucht,
eine App, die halt performancekritisch ist,
damit umzusetzen
und das vor allem dann am bestenfalls
nur auf einer Plattform published, weil
die andere interessiert mich nicht, weil dann hättest du das auch
sinnvoller machen können. Ja, stimmt.
Es gibt sinnvolle Gründe
dafür, das eine oder das andere zu wählen.
Stimmt, aber von App hier gibt es keinen Ansatz
zu überlegen, wir machen jetzt mit
SwiftUI möglich auch für Android-Apps zu bauen.
Ich würde es begrüßen. Vor allem SwiftUI
setzt ja nichts in der gleichen
Voraus. SwiftUI ist ja wirklich,
versucht ja plattformagnostisch dir
Möglichkeiten zu geben, einfach
nur semantische UI-Elemente
zu nehmen. Ich will eine Liste haben, dann nutze ich eine Liste
und diese Liste ist halt auf iOS oder
macOS was völlig anderes unten drunter,
aber das soll dem Entwickler
von der SwiftUI-Schnittstelle
muss es ja eigentlich egal sein. Das ist ja das Coole
an der Idee dahinter. Und es haben auch schon andere
Leute, auch Hörer dieses Podcasts,
sowas wie Swift Web UI
gebastelt, wo
man halt quasi ein anderes Backend dahinter
schiebt. Und das finde ich halt...
Wo ist denn da noch der Unterschied zwischen Swift UI
und React Native?
Das ist mal ganz plakativ gefragt.
Also
React Native,
das ist auf einer ganz anderen Ebene.
Aber
wenn du weit genug... Ich meine, der einzige Unterschied,
der mir jetzt einfällt, ist, dass du dann bei React Native
halt noch eine JavaScript-Runtime mitschippst,
die du da auch einstreckst. Wenn du das Problem von weit genug
betrachtest, dann verschwinden da tatsächlich
so ein bisschen die Unterschiede, das stimmt.
SwiftUI ist halt vor allem für
Swift geschrieben und
im Swift-Kontext sinnvoll nutzbar,
gerade was Swift-Typ-System angeht, gerade
was Swift-Features angeht und
da glänzt es halt natürlich, es ergibt
jetzt keinen Sinn, das aus einem anderen,
völlig anderen Tooling her
anzusprechen zu wollen,
Das wäre mehr Schmerz als Nutzen.
Aber so richtig Async-Await oder Asynchrones programmieren
kann man mit Zwift heutzutage noch nicht so richtig gut, oder?
Na klar geht das.
Du hast halt in Anführungsstrichen bloß kein Async-Await.
Aber es hält dich nichts davon ab,
wirklich sauber asynchronen Code zu schreiben
mit entweder den APIs, die Apple schon bereitgibt über Dispatch
beziehungsweise jetzt über Combine dir so ein Async-Await
halb hinzufaken.
Und da gibt es ja eine Hello Swift-Folge drüber.
Na, genau.
Aber es kommt bei uns jetzt nicht anders
als dieses Rx-Sternchen
beziehungsweise diverse andere Reactive-Frameworks.
Und letztendlich kannst du auf die Verschiedene...
Aber Reactive heißt ja nicht direkt asynchron.
Nee, nee.
Aber ich meine, darüber kannst du sie so ein bisschen zusammenfaken.
Und dieselben Ideen letztendlich da einfließen lassen.
Okay, okay.
Nee, aber genau.
Genug dazu.
Und zu Microsoft, glaube ich, haben wir jetzt auch alles abgehakt hier.
Mehr dazu auf Hallo Swift?
Oder zumindest, ja.
Also nicht zu dem Microsoft-Thema, aber...
Genau.
Obwohl, Swift hat jetzt halbwegs offiziell schon Windows-Support.
Also da wird es auch demnächst mal hoffentlich,
also bald das existiert,
gibt es eine offizielle Hallo Swift-Folge
nur zum Windows-Support von Swift.
Da freue ich mich schon drauf,
weil ich mich da dann mit mal auseinandersetzen muss
und mal anschauen darf, wie das so ist.
Ich habe so ein bisschen das Problem.
ich hab ja diese kleine
mein allererstes Rust-Projekt war
eine Desktop-Notification-Library, mit der
man diese kleinen Toasts produzieren kann
und das ist eigentlich, da spreche ich
einfach bloß auf Linux mit einer D-Bus-API
schicke da eine Nachricht hin und dann rendert meine
Desktop-Umgebung das
und
dann hab ich irgendwann zum
Spaß mit hier
Felix's Hilfe zusammen da noch
macOS-Support eingebaut, er hat
irgendwie so einen macOS-Wrapper für genau das
gleiche gemacht und das habe ich da noch mit reingehoben.
Wurde es plötzlich in dem Moment ein kompletter
Frankenstein, weil du irgendwie tonnenweise
Conditional Compile
Flags reinbauen musstest in den Code, weil
gewisse APIs nur hier oder unten nicht
da funktionieren. Es wurde sehr spannend.
Und dann irgendwann ist einer der
Maintener von diesem neuen Tauri
Projekt drauf aufmerksam geworden, wo wir
gerade bei unterschiedlichen UI
Frameworks sind. Es gibt Tauri.
Die findet man unter
tauri.studio.
Ich packe es dann auch mal in die Shownotes.
Und das ist quasi so eine Art, wir bauen Apps,
es ist ein bisschen wie Elektron.
Wir bauen Apps mit Webviews und anderen Komponenten.
Ich habe es mir tatsächlich noch nicht wirklich genau angeguckt,
aber die haben eine ziemlich krasse durchstrukturierte Roadmap.
Und eine der nächsten Sachen, die sie zum Beispiel einbauen wollen,
ist Dino-Support.
Finde ich ziemlich lustig.
Und da kam einer auf mich und hat gesagt,
ich würde es gerne nutzen,
aber wir hätten gerne auch noch Windows-Support.
Können wir das noch mit einbauen?
So ein kleines Feature mal, bitte machen wir.
Und da gibt es einfach auch noch eine andere Notification-Library,
die Windows-Support macht.
Und da haben quasi das noch als Rapper in Mainz eingebaut.
Und Mainz, was eigentlich ursprünglich eine Linux-Geschichte sein sollte,
hat jetzt quasi noch einen minimalen Windows- und einen minimalen Mac-Support.
Das ist nicht super schön,
weil du quasi den least
kommenden Nominator von allen drei Welten
hast, auf die Art und Weise. Also wenn du mächtigere
Windows-Notifications machen möchtest,
dann musst du das mit dem richtigen Windows-Dings
machen. Aber auf die Art und Weise
ist das jetzt da drin gelandet und ich habe gesagt,
das kannst du gerne machen. Ich kann auch
deinen Code reviewen. Ich kann bloß leider nicht testen,
weil ich kein Gerät habe,
mit dem ich das mache. Mir ist jetzt neulich aufgefallen,
dass ich mir auch einfach mal eine Windows-VM
irgendwie laden könnte. Da bin ich noch nicht
dazu gekommen. Aber Tauri, das ist
einer meiner Pics.
Wollen wir mal zu unseren Pics übergehen?
Ja, machen wir das doch gleich.
Also, ich empfehle
euch, wo wir gerade schon über unterschiedliche
UI-Frameworks
geredet haben. Erstaunlicherweise
redet, kommt noch jemand über sowas wie Qt,
aber es gibt jetzt offenbar MAUI
und
SwiftUI und es gibt
Flutter
und es gibt
jetzt auch TAURI.
Das ist aber eher für Desktop-Anwendung.
Und
da kommen, das ist so ein bisschen
verwandt mit Electron, habe ich gerade schon erzählt.
Sieht eigentlich
ziemlich lustig aus. Schaut euch das mal an.
Ich stürte mich ein bisschen an dem Hauptsatz
auf deren Landingpage.
Bundle your HTML, CSS and JavaScript
to make smaller, faster and more secure
native applications.
Ja, ja.
Das Hauptproblem,
an dem die meisten Sachen scheitern,
ist einfach, dass du
aktuelle schicke UI
nicht mehr mit den Frameworks von vor
zehn Jahren wirklich bauen kannst. Deswegen machen
halt viele nur noch
fettbasierte Sachen. Das ist doch völlig
verkehrt. Also ich kann jetzt nur aus der macOS
Richtung sprechen, aber eine aktuelle schicke UI
geht halt auf macOS fast nur
über die Cocoa APIs.
Gut, dann habe ich mich wohl etwas aus dem Fenster
gelehnt.
Das ist zumindest der Hauptgrund, den Leute angeben,
warum sie Elektron-Apps shippen.
Ja, also okay.
Weil Cross-Plattform-
schicke APIs geht halt...
Da gehe ich mit.
Wenn du Cross-Plattform sein möchtest,
dann ist es immer schwer.
Genau.
Du bist dran.
Wenn wir schon bei den Windows-Projekten sind,
ich habe mir hier so von Sean Griffin
ein in Anführungsstrichen Projekt rausgesucht.
Das Ganze heißt Notepadlogger.
Ist aus Witz entstanden letztens,
weil das so ein Meme, was kurz rumging,
auf Hacker News und Reddit,
Also zum einen Leute, die Raytracing in Notepad
machen, what? Und zum anderen
Leute, die einfach scheißen auf ihre
Debug-Konsole und einfach Output-Pipen
nach Notepad, was offen ist.
Ja, die Argumentation, die da
geschrieben wurde, ist aber doch irgendwie
sehr schlaghaltig.
Die Argumentation fand ich geil.
Du kannst es aufmachen, dann läuft da direkt
Output rein.
Dann kannst du es speichern.
Es läuft ständig deine Festplatte mit Log-Files
voll. Das war schon immer ein Problem.
Ich verstehe die Argumentation
voll, aber auf macOS zum Beispiel
gibt es ja die Console dafür, aber letztendlich laufen
trotzdem irgendwo Logdateien hin, aber du kannst halt
zuschauen, kannst es filtern, aber
ich finde es schon geil, irgendwie Notepad dafür zu
nutzen und Sean Griffin hier hat ein Projekt,
einen kleinen Rust-Crate geschrieben, die
quasi einen Logger bereitstellt,
der heißt Notepad Logger
und ein offenes Notepad sucht,
der sucht halt nach dem Window-Title
und pipet dann direkt da den rein.
Das ist aber auch bloß eine Adaption von
dem Original C-Code, der da auf Reddit
gepostet war. Ja, aber ich fand es schön,
nochmal als extra Paket hier, jetzt müssen wir es auch
richtig sauber machen für alles, was es gibt.
Und dann stellst du ordentliche Pakete als
Logger bereit und dann machen wir das darüber.
Ich muss das mal ausprobieren. Was ist denn, wenn du kein Loadpad hast?
Dann knallt es dir unter dem Arsch weg, ne?
Ja, vermutlich.
Das funktioniert wahrscheinlich auch nur auf Windows.
Es stand auch explizit
mit in der Readme von wegen
This was written by someone who does not know the Windows
API or its invariance and probably shouldn't
actually be used for anything.
Probably.
Probably, genau.
Was hast du hier noch als Pick?
Ich habe ein neues Spiel gefunden,
eines von diesen Relaxing Games.
Und zwar, kannst du dich noch am
Sandspiel erinnern?
Oh, diese Falling Sand Games? Genau.
Und von dem selben Typen, der das vorgestellt hatte,
der hat das sogar auf der
JS-Conf EU vorgestellt. Von dem gibt es
jetzt was Neues. Und zwar, das sieht fast genauso aus,
kannst du mal auf den Link klicken, das heißt
orb.farm, das ist die
vollständige Adresse davon.
Und der hat erstens für alle externe UI dieses geile 98 CSS verwendet, damit es wie Windows 98 aussieht.
Und das ist quasi auf demselben Prinzip wie Sandspiel basierend ein Aquarium.
Und da fängst du an mit einem großen, einfach mit einer Glaskugel und dann kannst du da Wasser und Sand reinkippen und Fische reinsetzen und Algen.
Und dann kannst du das laufen lassen.
hast da noch so einen Meter mit,
wie ist das Verhältnis von CO2 zu
Sauerstoff in deinem Wasser?
Und dann sterben die Tiere vielleicht
oder auch nicht, dann siehst du im Hintergrund total
geil so pixelig über
dem Ozean die Sonne auf.
Ja, du siehst die Sonne auf
und untergehen und je nachdem von wo die Sonne
kommt, wachsen auf der Seite von deiner
Glaskugel die Algen und
produzieren dabei Sauerstoff und du kannst
da kleine
Mikrolebewesen und Bakterien
reinsetzen. Ich habe noch nicht genau verstanden, was die machen, aber
fressen dann irgendwelche Überreste oder produzieren CO2 und leuchten im Dunkeln.
Das ist absolut geil.
Und du siehst jetzt auf Twitter, in letzter Zeit sehe ich immer mal Screenshots von Leuten,
die irgendwie total abgefahrene, geile Aquarien damit bauen lassen.
So nach dem Motto, ich habe es mal über Nacht laufen lassen.
Und das hier war am nächsten Tag.
Alles tot.
Ich mochte vorhin Sandgame früher richtig doll.
Das war, also gerade wo man so mit Öl und Feuer experimentieren konnte
sondern vielleicht noch so eine kleine Combustion-Engine
bauen konnte, die halt einfach nur
aus so einem Öl-Spawner-Öl immer verbrannt hat.
Und dann dementsprechend sogar, wenn die noch
eine Wind-Simulation mit drin hatten, wenn es ein moderneres Spiel
davon war, da kann man
richtig geilen Fuh mitmachen. Bei dem Original-
Sandspiel von dem Typen fand ich es auch
schick, dass du irgendwie Partikel-
Animationen, das sah trotzdem schick aus.
Du hast diese Pixel-Grafik
gehabt und konntest trotzdem irgendwie
Rauch,
hattest eine anständige Rauch-Visualisierung, das sah trotzdem
Und hier hast du sowas ähnliches, da hast du irgendwie,
das Wasser sieht trotzdem schick aus.
Das ist jetzt, könnt ihr mal anmachen und dann bis morgen stehen lassen.
Dann könnt ihr uns mal Screenshots von euren Aquarien schicken.
Nice.
Ich habe noch einen Pick, den habe ich gestern auch schon
im akkumulisierbaren Raum auf Matrix gepostet gehabt.
Das ist ein Talk, ein fantastischer Talk namens The Art of Code
von, ich glaube, wie hieß er?
Dylan Beatty, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Super cooler Talk. Ich will fast gar nichts darüber sagen. Also ich wollte mir fast nicht eine Stunde Zeit nehmen dafür, um ihn zu schauen, als mir ein Kollege den geschickt hatte. Der ist vom Februar diesen Jahres von einer Konferenz, die ich nicht zuordnen kann, NDC London. Und der fängt da einfach an, einfach mal hier coole Sachen zu zeigen. Und der ist halt instant gehuckt. Und nach 20 Minuten kannst du einfach nicht mehr wegschauen. Und es wird halt immer nur noch besser.
Und es geht halt von coolen Sachen zu Mandelbrotmengen,
noch mehr verstehen zu...
Geht es darum, wie man Kunst mit Code macht?
Sagen wir mal, es geht um Verbindungen zwischen Kunst und Code.
Und was ist Code eigentlich? Ist Code auch Kunst?
Und Kunst kann...
Also Kunst machen mit Code,
also er macht auch ein bisschen, nicht live,
aber quasi live mit ein paar esoterischen Sprachen rum.
und am Ende zeigt er so,
was eigentlich Rockstar-Developer sind.
Ich will es nicht spoilern.
Es ist einfach nur ein toller Talk.
Ich hab gerade mal ein bisschen
durchgeskimmt, die Videos.
Nein, tu es nicht.
Ich hab bloß kurze Bilder angeguckt.
Das sieht wirklich schon ziemlich geil aus.
Ich werd's mir nachher mal angucken.
Schau's dir an, das ist wirklich wert.
Das ist ein richtig, richtig guter Talk.
Super nice.
Jo, hast du noch was sonst?
Ja, ich hatte noch
einen Musiktipp.
und damit würde ich diese Sendung
dann auch zum Abschluss bringen.
Okay. Und zwar
gibt es den, und wir hatten
den schon mehrmals in der Sendung, es gibt den
Rapper STD Out
und den,
der hat schon vor längerer Zeit, aber ich finde es momentan
sehr passend,
einen Song gemacht, der heißt Remote Life.
Ah, sehr passend
zu aktuellen. Und ich meine,
wir haben gar nicht so richtig drüber geredet.
Arbeitest du noch von zu Hause momentan
oder gehst du schon wieder ins Büro?
bei uns ist alles noch, also man kann
wohl ins Büro gehen, wenn man möchte
aber man muss halt irgendwie Abstandsregeln einhalten
und ich sehe absolut keine Notwendigkeit
für mich, das ins Büro zu gehen
also bei mir ist es wahrscheinlich noch auf einige
Monate so, dass ich
von zu Hause aus arbeiten werde
und in dem Sinne
würde ich sagen
das war akronomisierbar
Folge 41
diesmal mit leichten technischen Problemen
aber willkommen im 21. Jahrhundert
Danke 1&1 für
Verbindungsabbrüche
Okay, dann
diesmal ohne Countdown, weil wir jetzt die Musik haben
Bis das nächste Mal
Macht's gut
Danke fürs Zuhören
So, das können wir uns jetzt noch in Ruhe geben
Meine Fische sind gerade gestorben in der Orpfer
Wake up five minutes before work
I got no pants on
Throw on a random shirt
The office life ain't for me
For nine to five
This is the closest thing to being free
All my friends live in a screen
Please send a link to your video stream
Can't remember the last human I've seen
Life on a remote team
All my friends live in a screen
Please send a link to your video stream
I can't remember the last human I've seen
Life on a remote team
Signing for the morning meeting
Cameras turned off so avatars are all I'm seeing
I just need a cup of coffee and some internet
Human contact, no I ain't really into that
Passenger stories, chilling with my cat on the couch
Home is so cozy, no I'm never going out
But I could leave and run errands if I have to
And I always shit from my own bathroom
I barely ever ever have to check in
I can stream Netflix and eat Chex Mix
Always message me on Slack
If you ever want a parent screen share
I don't even need to be there
All my friends live in a screen
Please send a link to your video stream
Can't remember the last human I've seen
Life on a remote team
All my friends live in a screen
Please send a link to your video stream
I can't remember the last human I've seen.
Life on a remote team.
Introverted while I'm working, I'm not sociable.
If I'm job searching, then this perk is not negotiable.
It's impossible for me to look presentable.
I don't even own clothes that are professional.
I can't let the office ping pong table distract me.
Rather travel, do some tasks from the taxi's backseat.
We hardly get together in a room, but it's all good as long as we have Zoom.
As long as we have memes and emojis for the group, I'd probably code in C before I'd ever commute.
Always message me on Slack if you ever want a parent screen share.
I don't even need to be there.
Please send a link to your video.
Can't remember the last few minutes.
Hey, hey, hey.
All my friends live in a stream.
Please send a link to your video stream.
I can't remember the last human I seen
Life on a remote team
Yeah, yeah
Ach ja, ich seh mich schon sehr an der Musik wieder